I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. It's The Merger. Hi, everyone. We're merging. Where are we merging to? We are merging two worlds today. Angela, the Stanford and the Scranton branches. Not all of the Stanford branch, but some will be merging with Scranton. I also feel like we're merging as friends because I'm looking at you. I think we have almost the same
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯尼。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你录制专属的《办公室》重温播客《终极办公室》。每周我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。这是“公司合并”。大家好。我们要合并了。我们要和哪里合并？我们今天正在合并两个世界，安吉拉，斯坦福分部和斯克兰顿分部。并不是斯坦福分部的全部，但有一部分将与斯克兰顿合并。我也觉得我们作为朋友也在合并，因为我看着你。我觉得我们今天几乎穿了同一
outfit on today. I mean, seriously, they always say pet owners start to look like their pets. Best friends start to look like each other. And husbands and wives and partners, I feel like we're starting to look like each other. We might be. Also, neither one of us has had a haircut or a hair color in a very long time. Hey, I did my own hair color, lady. I did too. Well, actually, Lee did mine with my hair colorist on FaceTime. I did mine, but no, I haven't had a hair cut. And I kind of have given up on makeup and just lipstick. Do you notice I only wear lipstick? Yeah, you show up to these zooms and in lipstick. I was
套衣服。我是说，真的，人们总是说宠物主人开始长得像他们的宠物。最好的朋友开始长得越来越像对方。还有丈夫、妻子和伴侣，我觉得我们也开始长得像彼此了。我们可能真的是。另外，我们两个都已经很久没有剪过头发或染过头发了。嘿，我自己染的头发，女士。我也自己染了。不过说实话，莉莉（Lee）在FaceTime上用我的染发剂帮我染的。我自己染的，不过不，我确实没剪过头发。而且我基本上已经放弃化妆了，只涂口红。你发现我只涂口红吗？对，你每次出现在这些Zoom会议上都涂着口红。我当时
walking out to my, that's what she said, to start the zoom. And I put on a little lipstick and the kids were like, why are you putting on lipstick? And I was like, because I'm yet because I don't know why I will be on a zoom. I'm gonna be on a zoom. All right. Well, this is season three, episode eight, written by Brent Forrester and directed by Ken Whittingham. Do you want a summary? I do want a summary. All right, good. The Stanford branch merges with the Scranton branch, which means Jim will be returning to his old stomping ground. Oh, I was so excited. Michael does his best to welcome the Stanford transplants, but he goes a
正走出我的办公室——也就是“她说的”（that's what she said）——来开启这个Zoom会议。然后我涂了一点口红，孩子们就问，你为什么涂口红？我就说，因为我等下，因为我不知道为什么我将要参加一个Zoom会议。我要参加一个Zoom会议。好吧，这是第三季第八集，由布伦特·福斯特（Brent Forrester）编剧，肯·惠廷厄姆（Ken Whittingham）导演。你想要剧情梗概吗？我确实想要个剧情梗概。好的，太好了。斯坦福分部与斯克兰顿分部合并，这意味着吉姆将重返他的老地方。噢，我太兴奋了。迈克尔尽其所能欢迎斯坦福的新人们，但他做得
bit too far causing one employee to quit. But Michael tries to save face by then firing him, leaving Dunder Mifflin with having to pay a sizable severance. Jan's not happy. Jan is not happy. Meanwhile, Pam senses something is going on with Jim and Karen and Dwight clashes with Andy. Good summary, lady. Thanks. You know what I started realizing? But you know how I have that Bible from the office, the office Bible? Yeah. Yeah. Every show has a summary. Every episode has a summary in the office Bible. So I've been able to now refer to the office Bible summary. I tweak it a little. I put a little ja ja on it. But yeah, I used to just sit down
有些过头，导致一名员工辞职。但迈克尔为了挽回面子，随后又开除了他，这导致邓德·米夫林公司不得不支付相当大的一笔遣散费。简很不高兴。简很不高兴。与此同时，帕姆察觉到吉姆和凯伦之间发生了些什么，而德怀特则与安迪起了冲突。干得好，女士。谢谢。你知道我开始意识到什么吗？你知道我怎么会有那本《办公室》圣经，《办公室》圣经吗？对。对。每个节目都有一个梗概。《办公室》圣经里每一集都有一个梗概。所以我现在可以参考《办公室》圣经里的梗概了。我稍微调整了一下。我加了一点我自己的风格。但是，是的，我以前总是坐在
at a blank page and think, how do I summarize this episode? And a team of writers have done it for me. And it was just sitting on my desk. So if you've noticed, my summaries are getting better. It's thanks to the office Bible. Wow. How excited were you when you realized there were summaries in there? You must have been so excited. Lady, yes. So excited. Fast fact number one. This episode was directed by Ken Whittingham. We've talked a little bit about Ken before. Ken directed nine episodes of The Office, including this one. And we reached out to him. Yes. And he sent in some audio clips. We're really excited to
一张白纸前想，我该如何总结这一集？而编剧团队已经帮我做好了。它就静静地放在我的桌子上。所以，如果你注意到了，我的梗概越来越好了。这都要归功于《办公室》圣经。哇。当你意识到里面有梗概时，你有多兴奋？你当时一定兴奋极了。女士，是的。超级兴奋。幕后花絮一。这一集由肯·惠廷厄姆执导。我们之前已经稍微聊过肯了。肯执导了九集《办公室》，包括这一集。我们联系了他。是的。他发来了一些音频剪辑。我们非常高兴能
hear him talk about this episode. And Jenna, he is going to come on and be a full Zoom guest for Phyllis's wedding. I don't want to get ahead of ourselves, but we're very excited. Yes. And Phyllis's wedding is such a milestone episode. And so is this. We wanted to ask Ken, what was it like to merge these two worlds? And a lot of people wrote in wanting to know how did they decide where everybody would sit in the office? Like if you notice, suddenly the desk pods go from two to three. Yeah. I remember being so happy that Ken was the one directing this because we already knew Ken really well. We were so comfortable with him. And
听到他谈论这一集。而且，珍娜，他将作为完整的Zoom嘉宾参加菲利斯的婚礼。我不想操之过急，但我们非常兴奋。是的。菲利斯的婚礼是一个具有里程碑意义的一集。这一集也是。我们想问问肯，合并这两个世界是什么感觉？许多人写信来想知道，他们是怎么决定每个人在办公室里的座位的？如果你注意到的话，座位区块突然从两个变成三个了。是的。我记得当时得知是肯来执导这一集时我有多开心，因为我们已经和肯很熟了。我们和他在一起非常自在，而且
this was big even for the cast. Jenna, there was a buzz because we hadn't been around these people. And, you know, we barely got to see them at table reads and things like that. So there was a real sort of buzz on set. And I remember being happy that Ken was there because he's so calm and like he was going to guide us through the merger. Well, here is his audio clip explaining how he and Greg decided where all the new people would sit. Introducing the characters from the Stanford branch would be very important to establish these characters and how they interact with the Scranton employees, their likes and their dislikes for
这对演员阵容来说也是一件大事。珍娜，当时有一种轰动感，因为我们并没有和这些人相处过。而且，你知道，我们在剧本围读之类的场合几乎很难见到他们。所以片场有一种真正热烈兴奋的氛围。我记得很高兴肯能在现场，因为他非常冷静，就像他会带领我们度过这次合并一样。好吧，这里是他的音频剪辑，解释了他和格雷格是如何决定所有新人的座位的。介绍来自斯坦福分部的角色非常重要，要确立这些角色以及他们如何与斯克兰顿的员工互动，他们彼此的喜好和
each other. I remember Greg Daniels asking me to decide where the new characters were sitting. Why? So he and I walked to set and I laid out where I thought everyone should be. Since Ryan had taken Jim's old desk, I decided that Jim would sit directly across from Dwight, which would be fun for Jim and irritating to Dwight. It would also put Jim in the middle of Karen and Pam, which will also make Jim uncomfortable and Pam to be able to check out interactions between him and Karen. I said Andy in between Kevin and Angela to establish Andy's instant attraction to Angela and also they would be in Dwight's
厌恶。我记得格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）让我决定新角色的座位。为什么？所以他和我在片场走了一圈，我排布了我认为每个人应该坐的位置。既然瑞安已经坐了吉姆原来的座位，我决定让吉姆坐在德怀特的正对面，这对于吉姆来说会很有趣，对德怀特来说则是一种煎熬。这也把吉姆置于凯伦和帕姆的中间，这同样会让吉姆感到不舒服，并让帕姆能够观察他和凯伦之间的互动。我把安迪安排在凯文和安吉拉之间，以确立安迪对安吉拉一见钟情，同时他们也会在德怀特的
eye line to create Dwight's jealousy. And he would later move on to Karen's desk. I placed Tony in the back near Toby at a very obscure desk because he would be quitting or getting fired in that episode. We also discussed how important it was to build Pam's awareness that Jim had moved on and was interested in Karen. I love how much thought went into where everyone sat. I love it so much. I love the idea of, depending on which character, who could see who, right? Yes. Yeah. And thinking about it from Pam's perspective, and I remember sitting at the desk and there's even a moment in the episode when Pam
视线范围内，从而引发德怀特的嫉妒。而他后来会搬到凯伦的座位。我把托尼安排在靠后靠近托比的一个非常不起眼的座位上，因为他在这一集中会辞职或被解雇。我们还讨论了建立帕姆的意识是多么重要，让她意识到吉姆已经翻篇并对凯伦感兴趣。我喜欢为每个人座位安排所投入的那么多心思。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种根据不同角色来看谁能看到谁的想法，对吧？是的。是的。从帕姆的角度来考虑，我记得坐在桌子旁，剧集里甚至有一个时刻，帕姆
realizes she's not going to be able to see Jim's face anymore. Yeah. There's a whole deleted scene about that lady where you actually come up to him and you're like, it's just kind of weird. I just stare at your back now. It's, yeah, it's a great deleted scene. And you and Jim start doing a bit. And then Ryan's like, can you guys stop? I'm just trying to get some work done. Oh my gosh, I want to go back and see that. Yeah. Because also after I heard Ken's clip, I was thinking about how, wow, so now Pam can see Karen's face. So if Karen is making flirty googly eyes at Jim or something, she doesn't know if Jim
意识到她再也看不到吉姆的脸了。是的。关于这一点，有一个完整的被删片段，女士，你实际上走到他面前说，这感觉有点怪。我现在只能盯着你的背影。这，是的，这是一个很棒的被删片段。你和吉姆开始演起双簧。然后瑞安说，你们能停一下吗？我只是想做点工作。天哪，我想回去看看那个。对。因为听了肯的音频剪辑后，我也在想，哇，现在帕姆可以看到凯伦的脸了。所以如果凯伦在对吉姆抛媚眼或者做什么，她不知道吉姆
is reciprocating or not because she can only see the back of his head. Yeah. So in terms of Pam trying to track this relationship going forward, she's only going to have that one thing she can see. I just, I just love, I love all the thought that goes into these choices. Yes. And I, and some people I saw wrote in and asked why would Andy sit in Oscar's desk and where is Oscar? But you have to remember, Oscar is on his paid vacation leave. Yeah. So his desk was available. Yeah. Although I will say this, Angela, someone wrote in to note that the character of Hannah is technically an accountant. Oh, yeah. So maybe that's
是不是在回应，因为她只能看到他的后脑勺。对。所以就帕姆试图追踪这段关系的发展而言，她只能看到那一个角度。我就是，我只是喜欢，喜欢为这些选择所投入的所有心思。是的。而且我，我看到有人写信问为什么安迪要坐在奥斯卡的座位上，奥斯卡在哪里？但你必须记住，奥斯卡正在休带薪假。对。所以他的座位是空着的。是的，不过我要说的是，安吉拉，有人写信指出，汉娜这个角色在技术上是一名会计。噢，对。所以也许这
another layer why my character feels so threatened by her. Yeah. Exactly. There can only be one bitch in accounting. All right. Well, I loved that. Let's move on to fast bag number two. This is the first episode featuring writer Brent Forester. Yes. And Brett also sent in audio clips. We asked him a lot of questions and he sent in clips as well. So all throughout this episode, you guys, we're going to have clips from Ken, the director and Brent, the writer, which is just so fun. Yeah. I love getting to have those different perspectives. So, Angela, you asked Brent about what it was like for him to write his first episode. Yeah. This
是我的角色对她感到如此受到威胁的另一个层面。是的。没错。会计部只能有一个碧池。好吧。我很喜欢这个。让我们进入幕后花絮二。这是第一集由编剧布伦特·福斯特（Brent Forrester）参与。是的。而且布伦特也发来了音频剪辑。我们问了他很多问题，他也发来了剪辑。所以贯穿这一集，各位，我们将听到来自导演肯和编剧布伦特的剪辑，这真是太有趣了。是的。我喜欢拥有这些不同的视角。所以，安吉拉，你问了布伦特编写他第一集剧本时的感受。是的。这
was his first episode and it's such a huge one. I was like, Brent, that feels very intimidating. You know, you're writing the merger of Scranton and Stanford. What was that like? Yeah. And this is what he had to say. Hi, I'm Brent Forester, the author of The Merger. I was not part of the original writing staff of the office. Greg Daniels, the show creator, was a writer with me on The Simpsons and he had me as a writer on King of the Hill. He brought me in in season three. And what I remember most about writing this draft was how I totally failed in the first draft to capture the tone of the office. I was trying so hard to be funny. I wrote
是他的第一集，而且这是一个如此重大的分部合并。我说，布伦特，这感觉太吓人了。你知道，你在写斯克兰顿和斯坦福的合并。那是什么感觉？是的。他是这么说的。嗨，我是布伦特·福斯特，也就是《合并》的编剧。我不是《办公室》原班编剧团队的成员。剧集主创格雷格·丹尼尔斯曾和我一起在《辛普森一家》担任编剧，并且让我在《山丘之王》中担任编剧。他在第三季把我招了进来。关于写这版初稿，我记忆最深刻的是，我在初稿中完全没有把握好《办公室》的基调。我当时太努力去追求搞笑了。我为办公室里的每个角色、
witticisms for every character in the office, every time they opened their mouth. And Greg was so horrified. He made Mike Sher, Jen Salata, and Paul Lieberstein, the three senior writers on the show, sit me down and explain to me the tone of the office, which is the tone of naturalism, where we don't require characters to be saying funny things all the time, where we let things be dramatic for long stretches and where we get comedy from performance above all. Well, I transformed as a writer between draft one and two of The Merger, and I learned the tone of the office real fast. Oh, Brent. Don't you love that? I
每次他们开口时都写了妙语。而格雷格吓坏了。他让迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）、珍·萨拉塔（Jen Salata）和保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）——剧中的三位资深编剧——把我拉坐下来，向我解释《办公室》的基调，也就是自然主义的基调，我们不要求角色一直说好笑的话，我们允许事情在很长一段时间内保持戏剧性，而且我们最主要通过演员的表演来获得喜剧效果。好吧，我在《合并》的第一稿和第二稿之间完成了一次编剧的蜕变，我迅速掌握了《办公室》的基调。噢，布伦特。你不觉得这很棒吗？我
just love that. I was like, yeah, I got it wrong. They kind of like let me know what was what, and then I gave it another try. Well, what people should know is that Brent went on to be a co-executive producer of the office. He ended up running the show with Paul Lieberstein, so he figured it out. He figured it out. Yeah, he did just fine. That's right. Okay, I'm so excited. We're going to have more clips from him coming up too. Yeah. Fast fact number three, let's talk about the transfers from Stamford. Yes, Stamford. Here are our new characters. We have Tony Gardner, played by Mike Brunner. We have Ursula Burton, who plays Hannah, and we have Wayne Wilderson, who plays Martin Nash. Now,
就是觉得，没错，我搞砸了。他们差不多是让我知道了情况是什么样，然后我又试了一次。好吧，大家应该知道的是，布伦特后来成为了《办公室》的联合执行制片人。他最终和保罗·利伯斯坦一起运作这部剧，所以他弄明白了。他搞懂了。是的，他做得很好。没错。好吧，我太兴奋了。我们接下来还会有更多他的音频剪辑。是的。幕后花絮三，让我们来谈谈来自斯坦福的转岗员工。是的，斯坦福。以下是我们的新角色。我们有由迈克·布鲁纳（Mike Brunner）扮演的托尼·加德纳（Tony Gardner）。我们有扮演汉娜的厄苏拉·伯顿（Ursula Burton），还有扮演马丁·纳什（Martin Nash）的韦恩·威尔德森（Wayne Wilderson）。现在，
you might recognize Mike Brunner because he was, he did have a small scene with Rashida in an earlier episode. Hannah was in the background of a few scenes over in Stamford. She had this storyline and some deleted scenes with Jim, but they had been cut. And then you might recognize Wayne because he had a big recurring role on Veep. And by the way, now he's in Greg's new show, Upload. Nice. And I want to take a tangent real quickly, Angela, to say that I'm really loving Upload. It is, I know it's like sci-fi-y, but I'm super digging it because I realized something about my sci-fi thing. What? Okay, I really like Black Mirror as well. And I feel like Upload has a type of sort of a comedic Black Mirror thing going on. Is that sci-fi? Is Black Mirror
你可能认出迈克·布鲁纳是因为他曾经在之前的剧集里和拉什达（Rashida）有过一小段对手戏。汉娜在斯坦福那边的几个场景中当过背景板。她有一条故事线和一些与吉姆的被删片段，但都被剪掉了。然后你可能会认出韦恩，因为他在《副总统》（Veep）中扮演过一个重要的常规角色。顺便说一句，他现在在格雷格的新剧《上载新生》（Upload）里。太棒了。我想快速扯远一点，安吉拉，说我真的很喜欢《上载新生》。它是，我知道它有点像科幻题材，但我超级喜欢它，因为我意识到了关于我喜欢科幻的一些事情。什么？好吧，我也很喜欢《黑镜》（Black Mirror）。我觉得《上载新生》有一种喜剧版的《黑镜》的感觉。这是科幻吗？《黑镜》是
sci-fi fantasy? Yeah, I would say it is. It's a lot of like alternate realities and sort of, um, yeah, it is. I think it is. Okay, is Handmaid's Tale sci-fi fantasy? Oh, see what I'm saying? This is the category that I like. I like a tiny spin. I love zombie movies. I love a tiny... I feel like zombie is horror, though. I know, but I feel like it's falling in this new category that I want to designate, which is like it's some of life as we know it and then some new rules. Slightly altered reality. Altered reality. I'm doing a lot of gestures right now. You are. I wish you could see Jenna. She's like cupping the air and then like spinning it over her head like it's a world, a ball. I don't know what's happening. Right, because this is reality. And then this is
科幻奇幻吗？是的，我会说它是。它有很多像平行现实和某种，嗯，是的，它是。我想它是。好吧，《使女的故事》（Handmaid's Tale）是科幻奇幻吗？噢，看到我的意思了吗？这就是我喜欢的类别。我喜欢带点微调的。我喜欢丧尸电影。我喜欢一点点……我觉得丧尸属于恐怖片吧。我知道，但我感觉它落入了我想要指定的一个新类别中，那就是它保留了一些我们所熟知的现实，然后加上一些新规则。略微改变的现实。改变的现实。我现在正在做很多手势。你确实在做。我真希望你能看见珍娜。她就像是在用双手捧着空气，然后像绕着一个世界或一个球一样在头顶转圈。我不知道发生了什么。对，因为这是现实。然后这是
altered reality. Here's the thing, Jenna, Handmaid's Tale. I don't think you can handle it. I watched it. It's fantastic. I couldn't sleep at night. I was like, oh my gosh. I watched one episode of Handmaid's Tale and I had nightmares for three nights. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And I've seen a lot of horror films, but that was, I mean, that got in my head. Holy moly. Okay, so... But here's what I'm saying. I feel like there is a, there's a tangent. Here's what I will not let go. I think there's a tangent of sci-fi that I'm super into and it's altered reality sci-fi. Okay. Fair enough, lady. Fair enough. Also transfers that you have to mention are Karen Philippelli and Andy Bernard. Oh my gosh, of course. Yes. Yes. We have those guys coming over as well. So it's a total of five,
改变的现实。事情是这样的，珍娜，《使女的故事》。我觉得你承受不了。我看过。太棒了。我晚上都睡不着觉。我就想，噢，天哪。我看了一集《使女的故事》，做了三晚噩梦。噢，是的。噢，是的。而且我看过很多恐怖片，但那部，我是说，它钻进我脑子里去了。天哪。好吧，所以……但我要说的是，我觉得有一个，这是一个题外话。这是我不会放手的一点。我认为科幻小说有一个分支是我超级沉迷的，那就是改变现实的科幻小说。好吧，有道理，女士。有道理。另外你必须提到的转岗员工是凯伦·菲利佩利（Karen Filippelli）和安迪·伯纳德（Andy Bernard）。噢，天哪，当然。是的。是的。这几个人也过来了。所以总共有五个人，
a total of five new employees from Stanford that come to Scranton. We had a fan question from a lot of people. Okay. Jesse Kay, Seth Anderson, Connor McColloch, and Molly Frank, all asked, did the writers and cast know that Martin, Hannah, and Tony, those three of those five transfers were only temporary characters? Yes, we did. We did. We didn't know how many episodes, right? But we knew they were going to be part of this new wave that came over that Michael slowly alienates. Yes. I remember that there was a conversation that was after the merger, each week, one of the new employees would quit until we were just left with Andy and Karen, or the two people who would stay. Yeah. All right, lady. Maybe we should take a break and then
总共五名来自斯坦福的新员工来到了斯克兰顿。我们收到了很多人的粉丝提问。好的。杰西·K（Jesse Kay）、塞思·安德森（Seth Anderson）、康纳·麦克洛奇（Connor McColloch）和莫莉·弗兰克（Molly Frank）都问过，编剧和演员们是否知道马丁、汉娜和托尼——这五名转岗员工中的三个人——只是临时角色？是的，我们知道。我们知道。我们不知道具体是多少集，对吧？但我们知道他们将成为这股新浪潮的一部分，而迈克尔会慢慢把他们边缘化。是的。我记得当时有过这样一段对话，合并之后，每周都会有一名新员工辞职，直到最后只剩下安迪和凯伦，也就是留下來的两个人。是的。好吧，女士。也许我们应该休息一下，然后
let's get into this episode because I have a big catch right out of the gate in the cold open and I'm really excited to talk about it. All right. We will take a break on that and we will be back with Angela's big catch. Yeah. Big catch. Oh, wow. All right, guys, we're back. We start at the Stanford branch. Jim has a talking head. He tells us Stanford branch is closing. Andy made Stanford RIP hats for everyone. Andy asked Jim what Michael Scott is like. Yeah, he wants some intel. He wants some intel. He wants to know how to work the system over there. Yeah. And Jim's like, you know what? You just kind of have to meet him. You have to meet him. But did you notice when Andy was asking him about Michael, he was like,
让我们进入这一集，因为我在片头刚开始时有一个巨大的发现，我真的好兴奋想聊聊这个。好的。我们对此休息一下，然后带着安吉拉的重大发现回来。好的。重大发现。噢，哇。好吧，各位，我们回来了。我们从斯坦福分部开始。吉姆有一个单人访谈。他告诉我们斯坦福分部要关闭了。安迪为每个人制作了斯坦福“安息吧”帽子。安迪问吉姆迈克尔·斯科特是个什么样的人。是的，他想要打听点情报。他想要一些内幕消息。他想知道如何摸清那里的门道。是的。而吉姆就说，你知道吗？你去了就知道了。你必须亲自去见他。但你有没有注意到，当安迪向他打听迈克尔时，他问的是，
what kind of magazines does he like? We know. We know what magazines. American Way. He loves trout. Yeah. He loves American Way. If Jim had given Andy the list of magazines, would that have helped Andy? I feel like if someone gave me Michael's list of magazines, I would be like, I am even more confused about this person. I am intrigued. Who is this person? So then Jim and Karen, they have a little moment. They agree this is going to be a big adventure. Karen gives Jim a real flirty flirt look, but Jim doesn't see it, right? But she's pining. Her heart is a flutter. They high five. I feel like Karen flirts and then Jim high fives, which for any woman that's into a guy, if you flirt a little and maybe cut some eyes at them and you
他喜欢什么类型的杂志？我们知道。我们知道是什么杂志。美国之音（American Way）。他喜欢鳟鱼。是的。他喜欢美国之音。如果吉姆把杂志清单给安迪，那会对安迪有帮助吗？我觉得如果有人把迈克尔的杂志清单给我，我会觉得：我对这个人的困惑更深了。我很感兴趣。这个人到底是谁？所以接下来吉姆和凯伦有了一小段互动。他们一致认为这将是一场大冒险。凯伦给了吉姆一个非常调情的眼神，但吉姆没看到，对吧？但她在单相思。她的内心小鹿乱撞。他们击掌。我觉得凯伦在调情，而吉姆却击掌回应，对任何一个对一个男人有好感的女人来说，如果你调情了一下，可能还抛了个媚眼，却
get a high five, it's like, I'm like, Karen, there are so many signs here. Don't do it. We're going to get into something I've started tracking called wishy-washy Jim. Oh, well, welcome. Welcome to the club. I mean, he's been wishy-washy for a long time. Yeah, but he does a lot of super big wishy-washies in this episode. All right. Now we're back in Scranton. Toby has come up to Pam at reception and he's talking about how he completed his run. And I have a catch. Oh, and is this what you teased us about before the break? This is what I tease you about. It's, no, I've set it up. It is going to be so lame. But at a minute, six seconds, new plant alert. Angela. At front reception.
得到一个击掌，我就会觉得，凯伦，这里有这么多的信号。别这样。我们要开始讨论一个我一直在追踪的现象，叫做优柔寡断的吉姆。噢，好吧。欢迎加入俱乐部。我是说，他优柔寡断已经很久了。是的，但他在这一集里做了很多超级极端的优柔寡断行为。好吧。现在我们回到了斯克兰顿。托比走到前台找帕姆，谈论他是如何完成跑步的。我有一个发现。噢，这就是你在片间休息前卖的关子吗？这就是我之前卖的关子。这，不，我已经铺垫好了。这可能会非常无聊。但在第1分钟06秒，新植物警报。安吉拉。在前台。
You have a friend in Hadley Lock who wrote in to say, Angela, is that a new tree at Pam's desk? Hadley, it is a new plant. It's in a maroon ceramic pot. Like not just like usually Pam's plants are just in like that plastic crap that comes from the store. You know what I mean? Yeah. This is in an actual pot. But Hadley, my friend Hadley, did you see what happens to the plant later in the episode? What happens? Where does it go? Hadley, did you notice that at a minute, six seconds, there's the one plant, but then go to five minutes, 25 seconds. It's a totally different plant. What? Whatever plant we used in the cold open, I don't know what happened to it. They couldn't find it. Someone got a different plant. It is a different plant. The plant at a minute, six
你的朋友哈德利·洛克（Hadley Lock）写信来说，安吉拉，帕姆的桌子上那是新植物吗？哈德利，这确实是一株新植物。它在一个褐红色的陶制花盆里。不像通常帕姆的植物那样只是装在店里买来的那种塑料破盆里。你知道我的意思吗？是的。这个在一个真正的花盆里。但是哈德利，我的朋友哈德利，你看到这株植物后来在剧集里发生什么了吗？发生了什么？它去哪儿了？哈德利，你有没有注意到，在第1分钟06秒，有一株植物，但是到了第5分钟25秒。完全是另一株植物。什么？我们在片头用的无论是什么植物，我不知道它怎么了。他们找不到了。有人拿了另一株植物。这绝对是另一株植物。第1分钟06
seconds is like small, light green leaves. And then at five minutes, 25, it's the big, dark green kind of leaves. And it's in a different pot holder. It's in like the clay looking pot holder. Whereas at a minute, six seconds, it's like a shiny maroon pot holder. Guys, I know this is what you're here for. But this is some serious plant gate. Plant gate. You have found the evidence for something I was wondering about. I think we filmed this cold open on another day. I think we inserted this cold open that it wasn't in the original shooting draft. So I think we came back and did this whole Dwight-Toby running thing at a different time. And that's why the plants are different. Yes, that would make sense. They knew there was a plant on
秒的植物叶子比较小，是浅绿色的。然后到了第5分钟25秒，它变成了那种大片深绿色的叶子。而且它换了一个花盆。它在一个看起来像泥土的花盆里。而第1分钟06秒那个则是一个闪亮的褐红色花盆。伙计们，我知道这就是你们来看这节目的原因。但这绝对是严重的“植物门”。植物门。你为我一直纳闷的一件事找到了证据。我觉得这个片头我们是在另一天拍的。我觉得我们插入了这个片头，它并不在最初的拍摄剧本里。所以我认为我们回来在另一个时间补拍了整个德怀特和托比跑步的桥段。这就是为什么植物不一样了。是的，这就说得通了。他们知道你桌上有
your desk, but they couldn't get the same one. So they just had to fudge it. Okay. Because here's because here's the thing. Pam takes Dwight down to the parking lot, right? Because he says that he can run faster than Toby, faster than anything. He's not impressed with Toby's running time. Jenna, he can run faster than a snake, a mongoose, and a panther somewhere in there. That's his speed. Right. So Pam is like, all right, I'm gonna, I'm gonna time you. And she makes Dwight run around the building. She's holding a digital thermometer. She has this sort of long kind of sort of a talking head. She's kind of talking out loud, talking to the documentary crew. And then she just goes inside. She abandons Dwight. We had fan questions from Spencer Brandon, Mateus Almeida, and Angie T.
一株植物，但找不到一模一样的。所以他们只能将就。好吧。因为原因在于——帕姆把德怀特带到停车场，对吧？因为他说他跑步比托比快，比什么都快。他对托比的跑步时间很不屑。珍娜，他说他跑步可以比蛇、猫鼬和某种豹子还要快。那就是他的速度。所以帕姆就说，好吧，我要，我要给你计时。然后她让德怀特绕着大楼跑步。她手里拿着一个电子温度计。她有一段那种长长的、有点自言自语式的单人访谈。她有点自言自语，跟纪录片摄制组说话。然后她直接走回去了。她把德怀特晾在那儿。我们收到了来自斯宾塞·布兰登（Spencer Brandon）、马特乌斯·阿尔梅达（Mateus Almeida）和安吉·T（Angie T）的粉丝提问。
Does Rain actually run around the whole building in the cold open? How did they time it out for Dwight to be running around the corner just as Pam finished talking? All right, Angela, I watched the scene. It is a one shot. There is no cut. So did Rain really have to run around the building? Well, you reached out to Ken Whittingham, right? And you asked him what he remembered. And he said, he did not film this cold open. No, which again, is further evidence to you that we filmed it on a different day. So someone else had to direct just this cold open because it was an insert, right? Yes. I was trying to remember shooting the scene. And I have a memory that, yes, the reason I'm talking kind of so slowly is because Rain really had to run. Yet at the same time, I didn't think
雷恩（Rainn）在片头真的绕着整栋大楼跑了吗？他们是怎么计算好时间让德怀特刚好在帕姆说完话时从拐角跑出来的？好吧，安吉拉，我看过这个场景。这是一个长镜头。没有任何剪辑。所以雷恩真的必须绕着大楼跑吗？好吧，你联系了肯·惠廷厄姆，对吧？你问了他记忆中的情况。他说，他没有拍摄这个片头。不，这再次向你证明了我们在不同的日子拍摄的。所以得有其他人来导演这单个片头，因为它是一个插入镜头，对吧？是的。我试图回忆拍摄这个场景的过程。我有一个记忆，是的，我说话语气之所以这么慢，是因为雷恩真的得跑。但与此同时，我并不认为
he ran around the whole building. So I reached out to Rain. And Rain said he cut through the warehouse. Oh, that's smart. So if you notice the camera pans to me, and he cut through the warehouse, through the building to the door on the other side, and then he ran around the corner. So he was still running a significant amount. Here's what I also thought when I watched that is, once again, Pam has become the gem of this office. She's the prankster now. She's timing him with a thermometer, making him run around the building. Pam is Jim. Oh, I bet she can't wait to tell Jim what she did when he finally gets there. Too bad. He's not going to want to hang out with her. Sorry. He doesn't engage. Well, we'll get to that. We'll get to that. All right. So now,
他真的绕着整栋大楼跑了一圈。所以我联系了雷恩。雷恩说他是穿过仓库抄了近路。噢，那太聪明了。所以如果你注意到镜头摇向我，他是穿过仓库，穿过大楼从另一侧的门出来，然后他才绕过拐角。所以他其实还是跑了相当长的一段距离。我看着这一幕时心里的另一个想法是，帕姆再次成为了这个办公室的明珠。她现在成了恶作剧高手了。她用温度计给他计时，让他绕着大楼跑。帕姆就是吉姆。噢，我敢打赌她等不及要告诉吉姆当他终于到达时她做了什么。太可惜了。他可不想搭理她。抱歉。他根本不接招。好吧，我们待会儿会聊到这个。我们待会儿聊。好吧。所以现在，
here it is. Dwight and Michael, they're prepping the office for the new arrivals. They're going around. They're putting name tags for everyone. There's gift bags. I have to think the party planning committee had to stuff those bags with pencils and coupons. You know, I wanted to discuss the gift bags, Angela, because I thought they were a really nice gesture. I think they are too. I, you know, I sort of appreciate we have to go out of town a lot right for work. And I always appreciate when the film company or the television company, they'll put like a little binder full of local restaurants and attractions for me to thumb through as I am now about to spend two months in this location that I don't know.
来了。德怀特和迈克尔正在为新人的到来布置办公室。他们四处走动。他们为每个人放置名牌。还有礼品袋。我不得不认为派对策划委员会一定在那些袋子里塞满了铅笔和优惠券。安吉拉，我想讨论一下礼品袋，因为我觉得这是一个非常贴心的举动。我也觉得是。我，你知道，我们因为工作原因经常得出差，对吧。我总是很感激电影公司或电视公司会放一本小册子，里面写满了当地的餐馆和景点，供我翻阅，因为我即将在这个我并不熟悉的地方度过两个月。
I think it's lovely to offer people little local coupons, suggestions of where to eat. Very thoughtful, nifty gift bag. Very thoughtful. I'm the type of person, if I check in to a hotel and they give me a bottled water, I'm like, thank you. Like, I don't know. I love small gestures. And I think this is really sweet. I do too. And I feel like it just doesn't get the sort of appreciation that it should. The nifty gifty bag. I thought it was very thoughtful of Michael. Also, I want to, I want to start using nifty gifty. It's a, that is a fantastic phrase. Nifty gifties. Nifty gifties. Nifty gifties. Okay. So as they're walking around prepping the office, Dwight suggests Michael Fire Anthony Gardner before noon to consolidate power. But Michael's
我觉得给人们提供一些当地的小优惠券、关于去哪里吃饭的建议，是非常贴心的。很周到、很棒的礼品袋。非常周到。我是那种人，如果我入住一家酒店，他们送我一瓶矿泉水，我就会说：谢谢。就像，我不知道。我喜欢这种小举动。我觉得这真的很甜。我也这么觉得。而且我觉得它没有得到应有的那种感激。这个棒棒的礼品袋。我觉得迈克尔非常周到。另外，我想要，我想要开始使用“棒棒的礼品袋”（nifty gifty）这个词。这是一个，这真是一个绝妙的短语。棒棒的礼品袋。棒棒的礼品袋。棒棒的礼品袋。好吧。当他们四处走动布置办公室时，德怀特建议迈克尔在中午之前解雇安东尼·加德纳以巩固权力。但迈克尔
like, I'm not going to do that, Dwight. I'm not going to do that. But he's planting the seeds. Someone must go today. Yeah. Okay. So at four minutes, Pam enters in. She's carrying food. Michael asks her to set it all up in the conference room. Jenna, you're holding two really big grocery bags. Yeah. And I have what I liked. I have what I'm going to start calling random prop alert. Yep. Jenna, you know the story behind those bags. Oh yeah. You and I both know. Those are fakey bags. They're fakey bags, guys. They're fakey bags. Here's what we mean. Those bags, they're, they're made of this material that won't make any crinkly noises. Yeah. It's super weird that it's almost like a fabric, but it's really stiff. Yeah. That's what she said. How would you
却说：我不会那么做的，德怀特。我不会那样做的。但他正在播下种子。今天必须有人走人。对。好吧。所以在第4分钟，帕姆走了进来。她拿着食物。迈克尔让她把所有东西都摆在会议室里。珍娜，你手里提着两个非常大的杂货袋。是的。我有我喜欢的东西。我有了我开始称之为“随机道具警报”的东西。没错。珍娜，你知道那些袋子背后的故事。噢，是的。你我都心知肚明。那是假袋子。那是假袋子，伙计们。那是假袋子。这是我们的意思。那些袋子，它们，它们是由一种不会发出任何沙沙声的材料制成的。是的。超级奇怪的是，它几乎就像一种织物，但又非常硬。是的。她就是这么说的。你会怎么
describe it? I don't know how to describe it. It's like, it is, it's sort of like a stiff fabric felt kind of exterior, but as soon as you spot one, you'll spot them in every show you ever watch. I'm telling you guys, any show you're watching where someone goes to the store and comes in with like anything that looks like a grocery bag, it's the fakey bag. Yeah. Because the real bags make too much sound for the sound engineers, for the boom operators. So the props department came up with these kind of fake bags and every single TV show uses them. You see, you'll see, you'll see. I, they fascinate me. The first time someone handed one to me, I was like, what is this item? What is this made of? This fabricy, stiff, filthy, fake grocery bag. Yeah.
形容它？我不知道怎么形容它。就像，它是，它有点像一种硬质织物毛毡般的外观，但一旦你认出一个，你就会在你观看的每一部剧里发现它们。我告诉你们，你们看的任何一部剧，只要有人去商店提着任何看起来像杂货袋的东西回来，那就是假袋子。是的。因为真袋子对音响工程师、对麦克风操作员来说声音太吵了。所以道具部门想出了这种假袋子，每一部电视剧都在使用它们。你看，你会发现，你会发现。我，它们太迷人了。第一次有人把它递给我时，我心想：这是什么东西？这是用什么做的？这种织物的、硬挺的、虚假的杂货袋。对。
Yeah. I'm always fascinated by them. And you're right. Once you see it, you can't unsee it. You can't unsee it because the brown paper bag, it doesn't look like paper. Look closely. It doesn't, you're like, what is that? You'll see it. You'll see it. Also, there's never any printing on it. There's never any like name of grocery store. It's just this solid brown bag. Yeah. So next Pam has her talking head and she is, she's excited to meet all the new people. She's excited to see her old friend. She's definitely in a good mood. We had some fan questions. Okay. Alice, 64, Jessica Scott, Harrison Perez, Amy Ardilla and Jamie Kearns all asked about Pam's hair. They noted that Pam's hairstyle changes from the little smaller,
是的。我总是对它们着迷。你说得对。一旦你看到了，你就无法忽视它。你无法忽视它，因为那个纸质杂货袋，它看起来一点也不像纸。仔细看。它不像，你会想：那是什么？你会看到的，你会看到的。此外上面从来没有任何印刷。从来没有任何像杂货店名字的东西。它只是一个纯色的棕色袋子。是的。接下来帕姆有她的单人访谈，她，她很高兴能见到所有的新人。她很高兴见到她的老朋友。她绝对心情很好。我们有一些粉丝提问。好的。爱丽丝64（Alice 64）、杰西卡·斯科特（Jessica Scott）、哈里森·佩雷斯（Harrison Perez）、艾米·阿迪拉（Amy Ardilla）和杰米·卡恩斯（Jamie Kearns）都问到了帕姆的头发。他们注意到帕姆的发型从那种较小的、
scrunchy curls to bigger, smoother curls. They wanted to know if this was intentional for Jim's return. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. For sure. Someone judged it up and then decided to wear a sweater that her mom made her because that's how you zhuzh up when your fellas come in. Let me get that sweater. My mom knitted me with the extra big button right in the middle. The button is so huge. All right, Angela Maggie Mendez, Diana Swanson and Morgan Ostrag all asked, is Pam's sweater really homemade? No. Look at it. No. I thought they could have done a better job of finding you a sweater that looked a little bit more homemade. Well, that was a store-bought sweater. They did alter it a little bit to try to make it look homemade. The giant button was an
抓夹卷发变成了更大、更顺滑的卷发。他们想知道这是否是刻意为吉姆的回归准备的。噢，是的。噢，是的。绝对是的。有人精心打扮了一番，然后决定穿一件她妈妈给她织的毛衣，因为这就是当你的心上人来时你打扮自己的方式。把那件毛衣拿来。我妈妈用正中间那个超大号纽扣给我织的。那个纽扣太巨大了。好吧，安吉拉，玛吉·门德斯（Maggie Mendez）、黛安娜·斯旺森（Diana Swanson）和摩根·奥斯特拉格（Morgan Ostrag）都问过，帕姆的毛衣真的是自制的吗？没有。看看它。没有。我觉得他们本可以找一件看起来更像是自制毛衣的。好吧，那是一件买来的毛衣。他们稍微修改了一下，想让它看起来像自制的。那个巨大的纽扣是
ad. Oh, well, great job. Oh my gosh, I am not throwing shade. I'm just saying. The sweater was hilarious. And to me, it's just... Listen, the wardrobe department did not have time to knit me a sweater. I mean, they got the script. What are they going to do? I guess they could have tried to find some homemade sweaters. We did try a bunch on, but here was the other thing. They wanted the sweater to be flattering. You know, like they wanted Pam to look cute for Jim. And so this was our compromise. A store-bought sweater that we altered a little. Mom, I need you to knit me a sexy sweater. Exactly. It has to be sexy, mom. And only one button, please. Now, here's something no one brought up, but I totally noticed. Purple eye shadow? Oh. Purpley eye shadow and a
加的。噢，好吧，干得漂亮。噢，天哪，我不是在贬低。我只是随口说说。那件毛衣太搞笑了。对我来说，它只是……听着，服装部门可没有时间给我织一件毛衣。我是说，他们拿到了剧本。他们能怎么办？我想他们本可以试着找一些自制的毛衣。我们确实试穿了很多件，但还有另一个原因。他们希望这件毛衣穿起来显身材。你知道的，就像他们希望帕姆在吉姆面前看起来很可爱。所以这是我们的折中方案。一件我们稍微修改过的大卖场买来的毛衣。妈妈，我需要你给我织一件性感的毛衣。没错。必须性感，妈妈。而且请只要一颗纽扣。现在，这里有些没人提到但我完全注意到了的东西。紫色眼影？噢。紫色的眼影，嘴唇上还抹了一点唇彩。好吧，我注意到了唇彩，不过显然我最近唯一注意到的就是嘴唇了。所以这就是你的状态，安吉。这就是我的状态。好吧，你知道的，新转岗员工开始到达了。珍娜，我们喜欢追踪各种事情。我想让你知道我追踪到了，迈克尔侮辱了每一个人，除了安迪。是的。我们看到了一系列由迈克尔·斯科特带来的种族主义和性别歧视的微小攻击。它们在这里：他告诉汉娜她的“累赘”在这儿。他叫托尼·加德纳“大个子”。他告诉凯伦她看起来很有异国情调，并问她父亲是不是美国大兵（GI）。然后他告诉马丁·纳什他要带他去看看所有奴隶都在哪里工作。是的。迈克尔总能找到方法，用完全不合适的评论来开启每个人的第一天。迈克尔。迈克尔。好吧，帕姆没法用那种让迈克尔重新来过的恶作剧了。你知道帕姆怎么总是第一次不帮他转接电话，因为他的第一直觉总是错误的本能。是的。汉娜第一个到达。迈克尔带她去她的座位。是的。他带她走到她的座位，他们走过了会计部。第4分钟41秒。凯文在座位上，但安吉拉不在。我是说，我觉得——你在哪儿？什么？凯文比安吉拉还早到公司？我只是随便说说。安吉拉今天有点迟到。安吉拉在哪儿？安吉拉在哪儿？我不知道。好吧。所以托尼·加德纳是下一个到达的。你猜谁就站在那儿？谁？汉娜。什么？她不是刚刚才被带到她的座位吗？怎么现在又回到前台了？
little gloss on the lips. Well, I noticed the gloss, but clearly all I notice are lips these days. So that's where you're at, Angie. That's where I'm at. Well, you know, the new transfers start to arrive. And Jenna, we like to track things. I just want you to know I tracked and Michael insults every single person, except for Andy. Yes. We have a series of racist and sexist microaggressions courtesy of Michael Scott. Here they are. He tells Hannah her ball and chain is over here. He calls Tony Gardner the big guy. He tells Karen she looks exotic and asks if her father was a GI. And then he tells Martin Nash that he will show him where all the slaves work. Yes. Michael manages to find a way to start everyone's first day with a completely inappropriate
嘴唇上涂了一点唇彩。好吧，我注意到了唇彩，但显然我最近只注意到嘴唇。所以这就是你的现状，安吉。这就是我的现状。好吧，你知道，新转来的员工开始到了。珍娜，我们喜欢追踪事情。我只想让你知道，我追踪过了，迈克尔侮辱了除了安迪之外的每个人。是的。迈克尔·斯科特有一系列种族主义和性别歧视的微小攻击。它们在这里。他告诉汉娜她的累赘在这边。他叫托尼·加德纳大块头。他告诉凯伦她看起来很有异国情调，并问她父亲是不是美国大兵。然后他告诉马丁·纳什，他会带他去看看所有的奴隶都在哪里工作。是的。迈克尔设法用完全不恰当的方式开始了每个人的第一天
comment. Michael. Michael. Well, Pam can't do her trick where Michael gets the redo. You know how Pam doesn't put a call through the first time because his first instinct is always the wrong instinct. Yes. Hannah arrives first. Michael shows her to her desk. Yes. And he walks her to her desk and they walk past accounting. Four minutes, 41 seconds. Kevin is at his desk, but Angela is not. I mean, I feel like- Where are you? What? Kevin made it to work before Angela? Just saying. Angela's running a little late today. Where's Angela? Where is Angela? I don't know. All right. So Tony Gardner is the next to arrive. And guess who's standing right there? Who? Hannah. What? Didn't she just get walked to her desk? How is she now back at reception?
她为什么不在自己的座位上？嗯。我觉得这是一个连贯性错误。我没注意到，但听到这儿，我不得不赞同你了。是的。她突然又回去了。现在凯伦到了，她和帕姆几乎是一拍即合。有一些很不错的打趣。如果没有吉姆，帕姆终于可以在办公室里交到一个朋友了，对吧？她会身边有个年纪相仿、对她很好的女性。是的。可以和她聊天。因为我觉得凯利对你很好，但凯利只想聊，你知道的，布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉的宝宝。是的，这倒也是。凯利对帕姆很好，但他们没有太多共同语言。凯伦是一个她真正能成为朋友的人，但并没有。不，这不会发生的。不。接下来是安迪在停车场的单人访谈。他快要到了。我喜欢这个单人访谈。他说他计划在几周内成为斯克兰顿的二把手。他列出了他的游戏计划。以下是其中的内容：重复、性格镜像，以及绝不松开握手。他说你必须永远像一个制作楼梯的木匠一样想在前头。我想讨论一下这个。我觉得这是一个非常好的策略。我有点想试试。不，不，珍娜，我看不出这能有什么好结果。别，我不知道。你不能直接走到某人面前，然后开始模仿他们说话的方式和动作。我不知道。我是说，
Why isn't she at her desk? Hmm. I think this is a continuity error. I didn't notice it, but in hearing it, I'm going to have to agree with you. Yeah. All of a sudden she's right back. Now Karen arrives and her and Pam, they kind of immediately hit it off. There's like some nice banter. If not for Jim, Pam would finally have a friend in the office, right? She would have another woman around her age who is nice to her. Yeah. Who she can have a conversation with. Because I think Kelly is nice to you, but Kelly just wants to talk about, you know, Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie's baby. Yeah. I guess that's true. Kelly is nice to Pam, but they don't have a lot
她为什么不在办公桌前？嗯。我认为这是一个连贯性错误。我没注意到，但听到这里，我不得不赞同你。是的。突然之间她又回来了。现在凯伦到了，她和帕姆一拍即合。有一种很好的调侃。要不是吉姆，帕姆终于可以在办公室里有一个朋友了，对吧？她会有一个对她很好的、年龄相仿的另一个女人。是的。可以和她聊天的人。因为我觉得凯莉对你很好，但凯莉只想谈论，你知道的，布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉的宝宝。是的。我想这是真的。凯莉对帕姆很好，但她们没有太多
in common. Karen is someone she could actually be friends with, but nope. No, it's not going to happen. No. So then we have Andy's talking head down in the parking lot. He's about to arrive. And I love this talking head. He says he plans to be the number two in Scranton within weeks. He lays out his game plan. Here's what it includes. Repetition, personality mirroring, and never breaking off a handshake. He says you always have to think one step ahead like a carpenter who makes stairs. I want to discuss this. I think this is a really good strategy. I kind of want to try it. No, no, Jenna, I don't see this going well. Don't, I don't know. You can't like walk up to someone and just start imitating how they talk and their movements. I don't know. I mean,
我觉得这叫性格镜像。这真的是个实际存在的方法吗？某个领导力研讨会上会教这个吗？因为这感觉非常像是安迪去参加了一个领导力研讨会，然后人家告诉他：这里是如何留下良好第一印象的方法。多叫对方的名字。是的，名字重复，并且永远不要中断握手。我不知道，安吉。我们可以试试吗？我来迎宾。好的。来吧。我是安迪。开始。嗨。嘿。你好吗？我很好。你好啊，安吉拉？你还没告诉我你的名字呢，变态狂。你怎么知道是我？你一直在跟踪我？神经病。我在我们见面之前谷歌了你。你知道吗？这进展很不顺利。我失败了。我干得太糟了。你用了三句话就失败了。噢，天哪。好吧。也许不行吧。
I think it's personality mirroring. Is that an actual thing? Is that taught at leadership seminars somewhere? Because it feels, this feels very much like Andy went to a leadership seminar and they're like, here's how you make a good first impression. Say their name a whole bunch. Yeah, name repetition and never break a handshake. I don't know, Ange. Can we try it? I'm going to meet you. Okay. Go ahead. I'm going to be Andy. Go. Hi. Hey. How are you? I'm good. How are you, Angela? I haven't told you my name yet, creeper. How'd you know it was me? Have you been stalking me? Psycho. I googled you before our meeting. You know what? This is not going well. I failed. I did a terrible job. You failed in three sentences. Oh boy. All right. Maybe not.
好吧。好吧。所以安迪到了。他拿到了他的棒棒的礼品袋，并且他执行了他的策略，迈克尔超级喜欢。是的。迈克尔觉得他棒极了，因为安迪在模仿迈克尔。所以迈克尔可能觉得他懂我。是的。他太喜欢了。我们收到了粉丝发现，安吉拉。噢。维罗妮卡·拉米雷斯（Veronica Ramirez）指出，当安迪在停车场做单人访谈时，他穿着那件棕褐色的夹克。是的。但当他走过大门时，它却不见了踪影。噢。他把夹克脱在哪儿了？他把夹克放哪儿了？他把它和那株别的植物落在一起了。他确实落在那儿了。它们在某个仓库里。就像在一个装着失物的大箱子里。是的。噢，天哪。你猜谁迎来了他的闪亮登场？吉姆。他和马丁一起走了进来。他们正在聊体育。帕姆几乎要翻跟头才能奔向他
Okay. Okay. So Andy arrives. He gets his nifty gifties and he does his strategy and Michael loves it. Yes. Michael thinks he's awesome because Andy is doing an impression of Michael. So Michael probably feels like he gets me. Yeah. He loves it. We had a fan catch, Angela. Oh. Veronica Ramirez noted that when Andy was in the parking lot doing his talking head, he has his tan jacket on. Yeah. But when he walks through the door, it's nowhere to be seen. Oh. Where did he take off his jacket? Where did he put his jacket? He left it with that other plant. He did. They're in a warehouse somewhere. It's like in a box of lost things. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Guess who's making his big debut? Jim. He walks in with Martin. They're talking sports. Pam about does a cartwheel to get to him
好吧。好吧。所以安迪到了。他得到了他精美的礼物，他制定了他的策略，迈克尔非常喜欢。是的。迈克尔认为他太棒了，因为安迪在模仿迈克尔。所以迈克尔可能觉得自己懂我。是的。他太喜欢了。我们有一个粉丝发现，安吉拉。哦。维罗妮卡·拉米雷斯指出，当安迪在停车场做他的独白时，他穿着他的棕色夹克。是的。但是当他走过大门时，它却不见了。哦。他把夹克脱在哪里了？他把夹克放在哪里了？他把它留给那个植物了。是的。它们在某个仓库里。就像在一个失物箱里。哦，天哪。猜猜谁在闪亮登场？吉姆。他和马丁一起走了进来。他们在谈论体育。帕姆高兴得快要翻跟头去见他了
and hugs him. Leads into his arms, really. Yeah. I was going to say, this is not just a hug. She like, she throws herself on him. Yeah. But can I say something? Say it. Seven minutes, 27 seconds. I have a giant zit next to my chin. And they have tried to cover it up. But it's like a little bit like when you try to cover up like super big zits. This is one of those zits. And I honestly remember it, believe it or not. And when I saw it, I was like, oh yeah, I remember that. It's one of those zits that feels like it's throbbing on your face. Yeah. It's a zit that has a heartbeat. That's what I call it. It has a heartbeat. And you can't squeeze it because it's so underground. But it's like a beacon shining off your face. And here it was, we had to film the scene where
Pam is going to see Jim for the first time. And I was like, I cannot believe we're dealing with this today. And the makeup department, I mean, they did their best. They caked a bunch of makeup on it. There's only so much you can do. There's only so much. And it's there. Yeah. And it still bumps me out today. It's okay, lady. I had a big zit in the Valentine's episode and all the photos we took, remember we did, it was like a whole first photo day. There's like photos of me looking up at Dwight, this like Valentine's photo and I have an enormous zit. So, you know. I can't remember what episode it is, but I'm going to ask Greg because there was a future episode that was like a huge Jim Pam thing. And I had another one of these big zits.
And then when I saw the episode, it was gone. And I swear, I was like, Greg, what happened? He said, you know what, Jenna, we decided to take it out in post. We CGI jerked it away because it was really distracting. How embarrassing, Jenna, that there was a roomful of people that you didn't even know who had to have a conversation about, do we have it in the budget to scoochie out her zit and post at it. And then it was someone's job to painstakingly remove it frame by frame. Yeah, it was so distracting. Oh, Lord. Well, Jenna, you're not alone. Hadley, who also noticed the plant, wrote in and said, at the talking head at three minutes, 55 seconds, does Dwight have a little pimple on his right cheek? No, why were we all so pimply in this
episode? Was it the summer where we just all hot and sweaty? I don't know. Maybe so. All right. So Jim now enters and Dwight and Jim are reunited. Jim messes with Dwight immediately by pretending like he's meeting his eye line, even though he's not. Yeah, Jim and Dwight are right back at it. And if you guys love to track a really good John Krasinski, do Dwight, go to seven minutes, 53 seconds. Oh, really good. Hi, Dwight. Nice. So everyone has arrived now. And we had a fan question. A lot of people wrote in. Kristen F, Sarah Hodges, Connor McCaulick, Erica Sansom, and more all wanted to know what was it like having all these new actors on set from the Stanford branch? And what was it like to have John back? I wrote about this in my journal.
Of course you did. Of course you journaled this. I said, we were really excited to shoot the merger. It was like we were meeting new people. The Stanford and Scranton branches shot on different days and different sound stages. So we almost never were together except for maybe just a few times. And we all really missed John's presence on set. So when the branches merged, it was the first time we were all acting together as a group. And it was a blast. Ed Helms made me laugh so loud. I pulled the phyllis and snorted. Oh, I love that. Yeah, it was great. It was great to have this new energy and new people. And I just have such fun memories of it. Yeah, I will tell you the place where I snort laughed when we get to it. Okay, good. I wrote a little note. Can we talk
for a second about one of my two favorite scenes in this episode? Yes. It is the Ryan Jim desk dance. Oh, yeah. Where they both set their bags down on the same chair. Yeah. I love it so much. They're both doing that sort of like polite thing like, oh, I'm sorry, are you was this you you're sitting here now or yeah, did you and then Ryan ends up getting the desk and I love his talking head so much. I talked a little bit about this with BJ where I said, as an older person, I am looking back on the office and I'm super loving the character of Ryan. I don't know what it is. I think maybe when you get older, you just you give zero more often and I feel like Ryan gives zero. I feel like you're you're connecting with Ryan because you feel like you finally age
to his place of zero f's. Exactly. I think that's what it is. And I just love his talking head. And he's like, yeah, Jim's a nice guy. That's why I got the desk. Yeah. And I'm like, that's so funny. Okay, I want to say something in the script. There was a different talking head. Oh, what was it? So that talking head that made it in was an alt. Okay. The talking head in the original script, Ryan was supposed to say, why? Because this is Ryan's desk now. Oh, I like that. I like the one that made it in better. Me too. Me too. I like the alt. Yeah. More layered. Well, Jenna, up next is a pretty big moment for the characters of the show because we have two adversaries meeting at nine minutes, seven seconds, Dwight and Andy. Yeah. Neither will break the handshake.
That handshake goes on forever. They see that they are each other's enemy. They know it immediately. I love that their rivalry is born out of a competition for who has seen more films or appreciates movies more. Well, you know, a director, a director has more power. That's, you know, that's Andy's whole thing. Yes. But Dwight has seen 240 films. Over. Over 240. Over 240. Yeah. Yeah. I'd love to see that list. He's got a spreadsheet. Okay. Well, we are coming up to one of my very favorite scenes in this whole episode. I have two. I think, I think my second one is maybe one that you like as well, but this one I loved. And if you're relating to Ryan, Jenna, I think I'm relating to Toby. Oh, because Jim comes over
and Toby is excited to see him. And I think Toby just wanted to be cool. And he tries to do a fist bump. And then Jim is like, Oh, is this what you're doing now? And then Toby's like, Oh, just forget it. Just forget it. I'm sorry. I don't know why I did that. And he has like, this such self loathing in this moment. And my heart just breaks for him. But I feel like, I feel like that's what I do. Like whenever I try to be like, I'm gonna be cool. It's like, Oh, forget it. That was lame. Oh my God. That was definitely Toby's glitchy up in here moment. Yeah. It got glitchy up in there, Toby. But it was so like, it felt so honest. Like it felt, I just loved it. Also, I have a little bit of a beef with Jim in this moment.
Same. He knows that Toby's trying to be cool. He knows that Toby just wants Jim to like him. And he should have just fist bumped him back instead of commenting like, Oh, is this what you're doing now? And sort of giving him shade. So I agree. I have issue with you right there. Just fist bump back. Don't comment on the fist bump. Just do it back. Agree. Agree. I need to bring up something called Shreddergate. Oh, Angela. Okay. Which version of this did you watch for our rewatch? Did you watch the iTunes version or the Netflix version or the DVD version? I watched the Netflix version and the DVD version because I watched this episode three times. Okay. I watched it on iTunes and Netflix. If you watch the iTunes download,
you will see a whole storyline with Kevin shredding things using a Staples Shredder. It has a giant Staples sticker on it and he talks about what a great shredder it is and yada yada. If you watch the Netflix version, this storyline is not in there. It is also not on the DVD. So folks who watched the iTunes download like I did, here is what that was about. This was an embedded advertisement for this Staples Shredder, which actually existed at the time and was launching and they paid the show to feature it on the show by one of our characters. They picked Kevin, something that people should know. Like if a show gets money to make a character drink a Coke versus a Pepsi, the actor does not get any coin for that. No, no, no. But also people
noted Staples is Dunder Mifflin's main competitor. Yeah. So it was especially strange. I mean, it's the Staples, theoretically, is the whole reason this merger is happening because that's how they lost Josh Porter. Yes. So it was an odd thing. It was odd. Okay, Angela, so now Michael is ready. Yeah. He's making everyone go in the conference room. Yeah, he has a gigantic performance, Jenna. That's coming up. He has named this the official merger day all family welcome breakfast. He's put out some food, but only the guests are allowed to eat and drink. Did you see the food though? It looked like little pieces of like toast and salmon. I didn't see anything else in champagne. Yeah. I mean, Pam carried two
fake grocery bags into the office and this is what was in it. I feel like this is on Pam. Is this all Michael gave her money for or did Pam just do a horrible job of shopping? Also was Angela Martin like, I did the gift bags. I'm out. I'm out. I have to say, I don't think Michael used the party planning committee at all here. I feel like Michael put together those gift bags. I don't know. I think the reason this buffet is sad is because the PPC was not involved. I think if you only have two items, it can't be a buffet. I think it's gotta be. Well, you're the buffet expert. I'm the buffet expert. I think it's like three items or more. Also, I love that on their very first day, he is going to insult them all and then also
give them champagne. He's like, Michael, Michael would be fired. Michael should already be fired. For sure. For sure. Also, at 12 minutes, 36 seconds, I see Mindy break. Oh, you do? Yeah. Yeah. So after Michael tells Kelly to consider the salmon to be poisoned beef, Mindy starts to break and puts her hand up to her face as she walks away. Oh, I have to go back and look for that. So, and we asked Ken Whittingam, our director, how did he fit everyone in the conference room? I mean, Jenna, we could barely fit in it before five new people. And remember, also in the room with us are two camera operators, two boom operators, and usually a first day D. So there were also additional crew members.
Should we play the clip? Yeah. To see what Ken said about getting us all in there. Yeah. It was very challenging staging and shooting the conference room scenes. I wanted to create a us in them kind of situation. So I put each branch on opposite sides. However, in the first conference room scene, Karen was the only person from Stanford that I put on the Scranton side. I remember Rashida asking me why she was the only person on that side. And I told her the reason being is to put her and Pam and Jim in the same shot to capture all their reactions when Karen passes Jim a stick of gum to peak Pam's curiosity. Okay. This leads me to Wishiwashi Jim and the stick of gum. Why is he Wishiwashi if he takes a stick of gum? Listen, are they dating or are
they not dating? Because when you bring a girl that you are dating into a new office where you used to work and then you don't sit next to her in the first group meeting, Wishiwashi, what is that? I feel like I'm watching normal people all over again. Did you watch that show? My God. No. All right. Well, yeah, I don't know what he's doing. I don't know if, you know, here's the thing. I do think he's Wishiwashi. I don't know if I support it in this moment because for all we knew, like, he went in to sit down and to save her seat, but then Pam sat down and now he's like, oh crap, what do I do? Maybe he's just a little deer in headlights. Well, then maybe he should have moved back to the back row and sat next to Karen. I don't know. Here is what I'm saying.
I'm saying we're going to learn at the end of this episode that they're dating and I don't think he is regarding Karen as a woman he is dating right now. I agree with that. Also, he doesn't even say who he's dating at the end of the episode. That too. He doesn't even own that. Wishiwashi, Jim. Wishiwashi. I actually got to sit next to Rashida in this scene and it was really fun. She was great and we got to chat in between takes and stuff. So I remember being excited. Oh, well, that's very nice. So Jim's loss was my gain. So there you go, Wishiwashi, Jim. There you go, Wishiwashi, Jim. Should we talk about Lazy Scranton, Angela? I can't wait to talk about it. This made me laugh so hard and of course, you know, there had already been Lazy Sunday on SNL.
So this was like inspired by Lazy Sunday and it made me laugh so hard when we watched it. So many of Michael's bits are based on the bits of Saturday Night Live and or other comedians. He really writes no new material. He thinks he's a world-class comedian. By because he just restructures and redos other people's bits. But he truly thinks he's like an amazing comedian. He even called this meeting, which should be just like a new employee orientation meeting. He calls it his gigantic performance. Yes. Yes. Michael reminds me of a cruise director. Oh gosh. Wait, that's perfect. That's all you need to say. I'm sure there's a story here, but that is the best example. Michael
is a cruise ship director. Yeah. You have to tell me the story. What happened on the cruise ship? Well, I took a cruise. This was when cruising was still happening and our cruise director like 15 years after Austin Powers had come out, his bit was to dress up like Austin Powers and be like, oh, behave. Oh my gosh. And I remember thinking like, has he been doing this bit for 15 years or whereas we are, I don't know. And then, of course, there was some Borat thrown in there. It was like watching Michael Scott live. But I'll tell you what, by the end of the cruise, I don't know. This guy, I was on board. By the end of the cruise, he was like, yeah, baby. Yeah. He was like, I'm in. By the end of the cruise, I was full on doing a scavenger hunt with my mom
and my sister. It was a cruise I took with my mom and sister. It was like, you know, a girl's trip. Girl's trip. Yeah. And we were with a bunch of other strangers and we were doing this scavenger hunt. And like, my poor sister is going to be so embarrassed to tell the story. The thing we had to find was just like a piece of woman's clothing. So my sister took off her bra and like took it out of her shirt and was like waving her hair. And she's like, we got it. And we were like, I'll behave. Oh my God. It wasn't safe. I love that story, Jenna. And you know what? Having now competed with your family and Family Feud, I know how competitive everyone in your family is. I believe that Emily was like, oh, we will win this. If I have to take my bra off,
we're going to win. She was. She was. And we, we didn't win. Oh, I'll say. Well, sadly. But we gave it our best effort. You sure did. All right. So we asked both Ken and Brent what they remembered about filming Lazy Scranton. And here's what Ken Whittingham had to say. One of my favorite scenes in the episode was creating the Lazy Scranton video, which was inspired from SNL's Lazy Sunday sketch. We kind of went off script and created a bunch of really funny extra scenes to make the video really hard to watch for the Dunder Mifflin employees. Unfortunately, we couldn't use all of them. Hold up. Are you telling me there's extra footage from this? Yeah, there must be. I need an extended cut. I want the extended cut of Lazy Scranton. I know. I know because this
was one of those moments where Rain and Steve got to go off on their own and shoot a bunch of stuff and we didn't get, we only got to see what the audience sees. We only got to see that final version. Yeah. Ken, I want those extra scenes. All right. Well, we also asked Brent and here's what Brent remembers about shooting those scenes. What I remember about shooting that Lazy Scranton video was just being in awe of Rainn Wilson and Steve Carell as performers. These guys are such serious actors and between takes, they would be talking about this performance like they were the Royal Shakespeare Company and then the director would yell action and they would suddenly become these cartoon characters bouncing off the walls like Bugs Bunny and then cut and suddenly they're
inside the actress studio for about two minutes and then action and it's Benny Hill. It was so wonderful to watch and it ended up, I think, in a kind of classic little bit of comedy film in the middle of the episode. I wish we would have asked them also about the little clip of Michael doing the Scranton Witch project. Yes. Because that's something else they filmed and I'm sure Steve did a whole bunch of stuff that didn't make it. Well, speaking of stuff that didn't make it, Brent sent us in some insight into something that I saw in the script, which was Michael went on to do a magic show for us after showing us Lazy Scranton, but we'll let Brent tell you about it. What I remember about filming this episode is that we ended up with too much
comedy. The premise for Michael Scott was so perfect that he would have these new employees and a new audience to perform for and impress that we just ended up writing too many comedy bits for him. And I remember one that made us laugh so hard. We had made a giant deck of cards for Michael Scott. And in the conference room, he says, if you put your heart into your sails, you will be a king of hearts. And then he has an employee pick a card and it is the king of hearts. And he says, and if you all put your hearts into your sails, then you will all be a king of hearts. And he flips his deck of cards over and they're all the king of hearts. And then he acts like he's blown their minds when in fact he's just done the worst magic trick ever. It was so funny
and we just had no room for it because the episode was so packed with good stuff. Angela, I remember shooting that. I remember the giant deck of cards. Yeah, and how he fanned them all out. Well, it's in the deleted scenes. Oh, it is. We can watch that. Oh, good. So if you have the DVDs, that one made it. I remember Steve's handling of the prop of the cards and the kings of hearts and how he did just like the worst magician handwork with the cards. I just remember trying so hard not to laugh. It was so hard to not laugh. All right, lady, that kind of sums up the first conference room meeting. Oh, there's going to be another one. But should we take a break and then we'll come back? Yeah, let's take a break
and come back because Andy continues to try to win over everybody. We'll talk about that when we come back. All right, so we are back and at 15 minutes, Andy is hitting on Angela. Is that what's happening? Yeah, he has put a cat dressed as a cowboy as his screensaver. Yeah. And he compliments your smile. What smile? Look at my face. I remember doing this scene and I remember Ken Whittingham and Brent Forster and I just brainstorming a little bit. How big would my actual smile be? You know what I mean? Sure, it wouldn't be just like it couldn't be a smirk. It couldn't be a full smile. It sort of was like this pursed lips barely reacting but slightly amused. So we did a few takes of like me sort of like trying to not smile but seem like I'm
somewhat happy. And that is something that I laugh thinking about because I remember Ken and Brent both being like, okay, maybe even less of a smile or okay, maybe you've got to do something. We were just like trying to dial it and find it. Well, I love where it landed. I think it's perfect and it is probably more smiling than we've ever seen from Angela Martin. So well, I think the biggest smile my character has had is when she realizes that Dwight gave her a key. Yes, that's the biggest smile. But this is this is amused. Yeah, slightly amused. Besides your smile, I was very distracted at 15 minutes, 50 seconds with your all brown outfit. This is a new color for you. You're usually in the gray tones. These are striking moments
because like rain almost always wears mustard yellow. But I noticed in a recent episode, he's in green. He's like, but it's monotone. Like that's the other thing. Both you and Dwight dress in like a monotone. Have you noticed? It's like, yes, absolutely. I mean, it was a brown skirt. And then I had a brown button sweater over like a black shirt. Like it was so weird. The whole outfit was so bizarre. Yeah. Should we move to the the heartbreak in the break room? Oh, lady, do you know what I titled this scene on my note card? What? Very hunchy. Oh, yeah. Very. But it's so true. And you know why she's doing it. Okay, Jenna, set up the scene. Jim is getting a water instead of his usual grape soda from the vending machine and Pam comes in
and she is finally she has him alone, right? So she wants their old banter back and she's like, oh, no grape soda, huh? And he's like, yeah, no, just water. He doesn't meet her there, right? And she's like, oh, you've changed so much. And he's like, oh, yeah, I don't know. And then Michael comes in and Pam tries to give Jim a little like look a little bit like, oh my gosh. And Jim does not return. No, he is giving you nothing back. And he says to Michael, you're not interrupting anything because nothing's happening. It's kind of cold. And he just leaves and Pam was like, yeah. And then Jenna, it looked like if you could have crawled inside your sexy sweater that your mom had knitted you, you would have because you hunch way into yourself. And I was like, oh, Pam,
so hunchy. There's a country song here called Heartbreak in the Break Room, Getting Hunchy. I was wearing a sexy sweater that my mama gave me. And then I went in the break room. And he broke me. So what did I do? I tried to crawl in to my sexy sweater. I got my heartbreak in the break room. Our country music singing is really breathy. It's not like it's not like peppy like country like there's a heartbreak in the break room. And I'm going to tell you why. Oh, good Lord. Okay. Oh, good Lord. Hey, can I put it out there? Anybody want to write Heartbreak in the Break Room? Here are your keywords. Heartbreak in the break room. Very hunchy. Sexy sweater. Mama's sexy sweater. Yeah. Mama knit me a sexy sweater for my heart
break in the break room. Oh, there it is. Mama knit me a sexy sweater, but all it got me was Heartbreak in the Break Room. Oh, come on. All right. So now where do we go from here? I mean, where do we go from here? Hannah is pumping in the bullpen. Creed is leering at her. Creed's so gross. Ryan is like, Hey, I'm sorry, it's distracting. Angela does not approve. Jenna, you and I both breastfed. We both had pumps. We had a pump at work, but I would not have pumped in a bullpen. No, I wouldn't have pumped in a bullpen. I've pumped in lots of places. I have pumped while driving down the road. I had a day while I was driving. I had a day where I had to go to a meeting and the traffic in Los Angeles is so bad that I was not going to make it home in time
to pump and or breastfeed. Yeah. So I put after my meeting, I got in my car. I hooked up my pump with my hands free bandana thing. Yeah, you had the hands free one. And I just pumped as I drove. I've I also pumped in a restroom at the airport. That was really the grossest experience of my life. I pumped. This was before airports had, you know, nursing lounges. Yeah. I pumped in the coat closet of the Screen Actors Guild Awards. I remember that. And Lady, a couple of years later, I did the same. And I remember you being like, Oh, Jenna, I'll show you where to go here. Here's this coat closet I used several years ago. Yeah. And I was like, Great. You really helped me out. So Jenna, now we have basically the Stanford branch and the Scranton branch trying to work
all together. And it's bumpy, right? It's like having that new roommate. And it is, they're having to sit next to each other like Creed is laughing way too loud on the phone. Hannah is pumping in the bullpen. Martin tries to have this moment with Stanley. And then of course, there's Karen and Phyllis. We'll get to that. Yes. Well, we got a fan question about that moment between Martin and Stanley. Kenya Hunt wrote in to say, as a black American, I personally lived for the really intimate details about blackness in the show, like Darrell teaching Michael, Dinkin Flicka, for example. Another example is the moment between Martin and Stanley in this episode. Martin tries to give Stanley the black nod. The nod black people give each other as a
sign of understanding in mostly white spaces. And Stanley rejects him. It is too funny. Who wrote that part or was it improvised? Well, we asked Brent Forrester, our writer about that. And here's what he had to say. That was written into the script, but the performers Leslie David Baker and the great Wayne Wilderson who played Martin, they did make it their own. And it was directed by Ken Whittingham, who I remember thought it was very, very funny. And yeah, that was that was a collaboration for sure. So glad you like that. And here's what our director Ken had to say about that moment. The interaction between Martin and Stanley was written by Brent Forrester. And yes, it was scripted. And I laugh out loud every time I watch it. It just really
kills me. Some of us know that guy. Okay, so now is one of my favorite scenes in this whole episode. Same. I mean, we didn't even talk about this. And then this morning when we were getting ready to do it, it's we both had this scene down is like, we've got to hear the scene because we love it so much. Karen is sitting at her desk and she is like, what is that smell? Smells like a funeral home. Smells like a funeral home, she says. Yeah, we come to find out it's Phyllis's perfume. Phyllis is like, Oh, I'll help you find the smell. And then Karen is like, Oh, oh, I think I'm allergic to your perfume. And Phyllis has a response that I love so much. This is, this is Phyllis Sass, right, Angela? Such Phyllis Sass. So much so there's part of it I want on a t-shirt. It's so great.
Can we play a clip of it? Yes, please. Oh, you know, never, never mind. What is it? Oh, I think I'm just allergic to your perfume. My perfume? It's just my crazy nose. I used to different smells. Bob Vance bought this perfume for me in Metropolitan, Orlando. It's made from real pine. Who's Bob Vance? You have a lot to learn about this town, sweetie. Oh, the first lady of Vance refrigeration is not pleased. Phyllis is pissed. Yeah. First of all, she insults her perfume, and it's from Metropolitan, Orlando. Hello. Yeah, it's made with real pine, Angela. Then Karen doesn't know who Bob Vance is. Oh, good luck, Karen. Good luck. You really stepped in it, Karen. And Stanley has that amazing talking head where he is like, I don't know who these new people think
they are, but I have sat downwind of Phyllis's stinky perfume for years and I have never said a word. Yeah. Oh, man, no one's getting along. No one's getting along from the new branch, and it's all going to come to a head. I love throughout the series the sort of subtle tension that happens from time to time between Phyllis and Stanley. I have to say, every once in a while, Phyllis gets real annoyed with him, and then now we're getting a peek into what Stanley has endured in that desk clump, years of this perfume. They're like an old married couple. The two of them. They really are. They have each other's back, but they also like drive each other crazy, but it's a sort of like subtle, quiet anger. They definitely eat dinner in silence, right? Yeah. They're that couple
in the restaurant, and they haven't said a word for 30 minutes. It's because they've been together so long. They've said everything they need to say. Exactly. Exactly. Oh, I love it so much. Angela, I have to point something out here. This is a tangent, but it's short. You know, we're talking about how this is Phyllis Sass. You really coined the sass. A fan sent in that on one of our episodes in the podcast notes, it says that our guest on the episode is Michael Sass. What? Yes. Like on the Apple download site, it says like our guests are, and then it lists the guests, and one of the guests is Michael Sass. There's no photo for him, though. That is hilarious. Whatever the algorithm is that like listens to your podcast and then picks out guest stars to highlight, somehow this
computer program believes that there's someone on our podcast named Michael Sass. Because we've said sass so many times. It's now like the thing the computer picks up on. Yeah. Sass is one of our guest stars. Man. All right. So guys, it's hard to believe, but Michael didn't feel like one conference room meeting was enough. He makes everyone go inside for what he's now calling the integration celebration. Well, he's really noticed that no one's getting along and he's worried about it. And so he says, you know, I mean, a great show can make people forget about their differences. You got to give them another great show, everybody. Yeah. So what he decides to do is re-enact another Saturday Night Live bit, this time night at the Roxbury. And this is what Michael
电脑程序以为我们播客里有个叫迈克尔·萨斯的人。因为我们说了太多次“萨斯”这个词。现在这成了电脑捕捉到的一个梗。没错。萨斯成了我们的特邀嘉宾之一。天哪。好吧。伙计们，真难以置信，但迈克尔觉得开一次会议还不够。他让所有人进屋，参加他现在所谓的融合庆典。好吧，他真的发现没有人能合得来，他为此很担心。所以他说，你知道的，我的意思是，一场精彩的表演能让人忘记分歧。你必须给大家再奉献一场精彩的表演，各位。没错。于是他决定重新演绎另一个《周六夜现场》的桥段，这一次是《今夜罗克斯伯里》。这就是迈克尔
thinks. This is the way to bring everyone together. Yeah. It's to imitate these idiots at the night club. But his boombox doesn't work. So Andy comes to the rescue and he sings for him. Andy starts going pang-a-pong, ping-pong, ping-pong, ping-pong, ping-pong, right? He starts doing that. Well, none of us knew what that was going to sound like, really, right? Yeah. It was just in the script that he would provide the music. Right. And so I don't think we were really prepared for Ed Helms as Andy to go full out. And we lost it. And that's when I did my snort laugh because we're all in this little room. And it's totally quiet. And then with full commitment, Ed is like, ping-pong, ping-pong, ping-pong. It was like so crazy. Sorry, I dropped my pencil. I was like, ah, it was crazy.
心里的想法。这就是把所有人凝聚在一起的方式。没错。就是模仿夜总会里的这些笨蛋。但他的手提音响坏了。于是安迪挺身而出，为他唱歌。安迪开始“砰——阿——砰，乒——乓，乒——乓，乒——乓，乒——乓”地唱起来，对吧？他开始这样唱。好吧，我们谁也不知道这听起来会是什么样，真的，对吧？剧本里只写了他会提供音乐。没错。所以我认为我们真的没有做好准备，看埃德·海尔姆斯饰演的安迪完全放飞自我。我们彻底笑崩了。那就是我笑出猪叫的时候，因为我们都在这个小房间里。而且四周一片寂静。接着埃德全情投入地发出“乒——乓，乒——乓，乒——乓”的声音。这太疯狂了。抱歉，我铅笔掉了。我当时就想，啊，这太疯狂了。
That was amazing. I'll never forget that. And also remember, Ed was new to us. So we were like, oh, oh, he showed up in full uniform ready to play today. Yeah. We didn't know it was coming. Yeah. That made us laugh so hard. So next, Michael asks all of the new employees to sit up on the conference table. This is to illustrate that the older employees are not above them. I have some fun trivia from Dunderpedia about this moment. Okay, Dunderpedia. What do you got? Dunderpedia notes that in the British version, they have an episode called Motivation. And the manager, David Brent, says he would never make his employees stand on a table because it's against health and safety regulations.
太棒了。我永远不会忘记那一幕。而且还要记住，埃德对我们来说是个新人。所以我们当时想，哦，哦，他今天穿得整整齐齐、全副武装准备开工了。没错。我们根本不知道会有这一出。没错。这把我们逗得前仰后合。接下来，迈克尔让所有新员工坐在会议桌上。这以此说明老员工并不在他们之上。我从邓德百科上找到了关于这一刻的一些有趣冷知识。好的，邓德百科。你有什么料？邓德百科指出，在英国版中，他们有一集叫《激励》。经理大卫·布伦特说他绝不会让员工站在桌子上，因为这违反了健康和安全条例。
It's kind of a fun little thing. Fun little thing. I guess Michael never read the health and safety almost ever. Clearly. This is Toby's whole life is having to try to catch Michael up on every regulation. Yeah. So there's one person who's not on the table. It's Tony. And Michael says, Tony, let's get you up on the table, right? And Tony is like, yeah, I can't. I can't get on the table. And Michael's like, no, yes, you can. He's thinking there's like, right, like he's like giving him a pep talk to get on the table. And then Tony is like, no, I like, I physically can't get on the table. But Michael will not let it go. He's like, we'll help you. We will physically help you get on the table. Yeah. And then he gets Dwight involved. And, and then it's just,
这算是一个有趣的小细节。有趣的小细节。我猜迈克尔几乎从来没读过健康 and 安全条例。显然如此。托比的整个生活就是不得不试图让迈克尔赶上每一条规章制度。没错。所以有一个人没有站在桌子上。那就是托尼。迈克尔说：“托尼，让我们也让你站到桌子上去，好吗？”托尼却说：“不行，我不能。我上不了桌子。”迈克尔就说：“不，行，你可以的。”他心想，对吧，就像他在给他做心理建设，好让他上桌子一样。然后托尼就说：“不，我，我身体上根本上不了桌子。”但迈克尔就是不肯罢休。他说：“我们会帮你的。我们会从体力上帮你的，让你站到桌子上去。”没错。然后他把德怀特也卷了进来，接着事情就变成了，
it's really cringy. And I remember, like, even when we were there being like, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. And then, you know, Tony is like, stop it. I'm done. I am done. Yes. And he says, I can't work here. I can't work here. And of course, Michael is like, oh my god, is it Toby? And Tony's like, no, Toby was actually very kind and helpful. It is you. It is your management style. But like Tony is being nicer about it than I am. He's like, no, Michael, it's your management style. And Michael cannot believe it. He cannot believe that there would be someone who doesn't think he's an awesome manager. Michael cannot hold up the mirror to see himself. He just can't. And throughout the course of this day, he's been disrespectful to all the new employees.
这真的让人脚趾抠地。我记得，甚至当时我们在场的时候都在想：“天哪，天哪，天哪。”然后，你知道的，托尼就说：“够了。我受够了。我真的受够了。”没错。他说：“我没法在这里工作。我没法在这里工作。”当然，迈克尔就说：“天哪，是托比吗？”托尼却说：“不，托比其实非常友善，也很乐于助人。是你。是你的管理风格。”但托尼说得比我要温和。他说：“不，迈克尔，是你的管理风格。”迈克尔简直不敢相信。他简直不敢相信居然会有人觉得他不是一个伟大的经理。迈克尔根本无法照镜子看看自己。他就是做不到。而且在这整整一天里，他对所有新员工都非常不尊重。
And Tony has had it. He's not going to work in this environment anymore. But of course, Michael gets hurt and embarrassed and turns it around and says, you know what? You're fired. I'm firing you to Dwight's delight. Dwight is like, that's what I said. I said we should fire him. So Dwight takes it as a win. And Tony is just like, I, it, I can't. I can't even. Yeah. And you start to see that Hannah is like, yeah, he's, he's got the right idea, right? Yes. And it's unraveling. All of this is unraveling. And Michael is starting to spiral. Now, we had a few fan catches and questions about this scene. First, I'm going to give you this fan catch from Luke Jensen. He says, I noticed a potentially huge
而托尼已经忍无可忍了。他再也不想在这种环境下工作了。但当然，迈克尔受到了伤害和羞辱，于是反咬一口说：“你知道吗？你被解雇了。我开除你。”这让德怀特欣喜若狂。德怀特心想：“我就这么说的。我说过我们应该开除他。”所以德怀特把这当成了一场胜利。而托尼则是一副“我，这，我简直了。我简直没法说什么了”的表情。没错。你开始看到汉娜觉得，没错，他，他说的有道理，对吧？是的。一切都在土崩瓦解。所有这一切都在崩溃。而迈克尔开始失控了。现在，我们关于这个场景收到了一些粉丝的抓包和提问。首先，我要把卢克·詹森的这个粉丝抓包分享给大家。他说，我注意到一个潜在的巨大
mistake in season three, episode eight, the merger. The episode depicts the entire merger day and Tony Gardner gets fired, right? Yeah. But then in the threat level midnight movie, Tony Gardner is playing the piano. How is it that Tony Gardner ended up in this movie of threat level midnight? There's no way that Michael filmed threat level midnight on this one merger day. Right? That is a great catch. Here's the thing, BJ Novak gave an interview about this. Oh, BJ said that the writers thought that it would be very funny for Tony Gardner to have a cameo in threat level midnight. And they have this whole weird backstory as to why he appears in threat level midnight. They think that Michael had this realization. And he called up Tony Gardner and
失误，在第三季第八集《公司合并》里。这集讲述了整个合并日，而且托尼·加德纳被解雇了，对吧？没错。但后来在电影《威胁等级：午夜》里，托尼·加德纳却在弹钢琴。托尼·加德纳怎么会跑到《威胁等级：午夜》这部电影里去的？迈克尔绝不可能刚好在这同一个合并日里拍摄《威胁等级：午夜》吧？这是一个超级棒的抓包。事情是这样的，B·J·诺瓦克曾就此接受过一次采访。哦，B·J说，编剧们认为让托尼·加德纳在《威胁等级：午夜》中客串会非常有趣。而且他们为此编造了一整套奇怪的背景故事，解释他为什么会出现在《威胁等级：午夜》里。他们认为迈克尔意识到了这一点，
apologized profusely for the way he treated him and then said, I would like to offer you a role in my movie. And Tony was like, BJ in the interview says like, in his mind, Tony was like either like, well, I don't know, I have nothing else better to do. Like maybe he's bored. He's like, maybe he wanted to be in a movie. Maybe he was the aspiring actor on the side. Maybe he's a cinephile. And I was like, yeah, I'd like to be in a movie. Why not? I'll be in your movie. But that this was, this was like a choice that they would have this person that Michael wronged in an earlier episode have this cameo in threat level midnight. I like it. I like it. So there you go. I want Michael to have growth. I want him to learn and evolve. Now here's another fan question from this moment.
并为自己对待他的方式深表歉意，然后说：“我想在我的电影里为你提供一个角色。”托尼当时就觉得——B·J在采访中说——在托尼的心里，他要么会想：“嗯，我不知道，我也没有别的更好的事可做了。”也许他当时觉得无聊。他会想：“也许他想参演一部电影呢。”也许他是个暗地里有演员梦的人。也许他是个影迷。然后我想：“行啊，我想拍电影。为什么不呢？我要演你的电影。”但这就是，这就是他们的一个选择，让这个在前面某一集里被迈克尔冤枉的人在《威胁等级：午夜》里客串一把。我喜欢。我喜欢。所以就是这样。我希望迈克尔能有所成长。我希望他能学习并进化。现在，关于这个时刻还有另一个粉丝提问。
At 22 minutes 56 seconds, Tim Althouse, Sidney Paul's Ben Pavey, Grace Bromley, and Declan Jensen all want to know who is the man wearing business attire who is standing next to Andy in the conference room when Michael fires Tony? Did you notice it, Ange? Oh, I noticed it. I noticed it. And I, and then I saw all the questions purring in about it. Yeah, Philip Santani. That's who that is, guys. He was one of our male standings for the actors. It was Philip and Steven Socks were our two male standings. And you will probably spot Steven in some future episodes in some scenes. And his wife, Lori, has already been in one. That's who that was. Good catch. Good catch, guys. Very good catch. So Michael's really bombed. He says that today was supposed to be a love union,
在影片22分56秒处，蒂姆·阿尔特豪斯、西德尼·保罗的本·佩维、格蕾丝·布罗姆利和德克兰·詹森都想知道，当迈克尔解雇托尼时，站在会议室安迪身旁穿商务正装的那个男人是谁？你注意到了吗，安吉？哦，我注意到了。我注意到了。而且我，然后我看到所有关于这事的提问雪花般飞来。没错，菲利普·圣塔尼。伙计们，那就是他。他是我们演员的男替身之一。菲利普和史蒂芬·索克斯是我们两个男替身。你们可能会在未来的某些剧集和场景中认出史蒂芬。他的妻子洛瑞已经出场过一次了。那就是他。抓得好。抓得好，伙计们。抓得太棒了。所以迈克尔真是搞砸了。他说今天本该是一场爱的联盟，
but it's more like when his mom moved in with Jeff. And now his job is to fix it. He's got to fix it, you guys. And how does he decide to fix it? He goes into the parking lot and lets the air out of everyone's tire. And he's like, Oh my God, we got punked. You know, they, they got us good. Come see. Like he thinks this is going to bring everyone together. Yeah, that's right. But Angela, everyone's tires except Michael's. Yes. And he got a hate note that says that, that you guys suck. It's from Vance refrigeration. And that they suck. Because Vance refrigeration would suddenly, for no reason, decide to hate on Dunder Mifflin. It makes so much sense. But they would spare Michael's car. Well, they saved the worst for him with the hate note, according to Michael. Yeah. And
但它更像他妈妈和杰夫同居的时候。现在他的工作是修复这一切。他必须修复这一切，伙计们。他是怎么决定修复这一切的呢？他走到停车场，把每个人的车胎气都放了。然后他说：“天哪，我们被整蛊了。”你知道的，他们，他们把我们整得够惨。快来看。就像他以为这能把所有人凝聚在一起一样。没错，就是这样。但安吉拉，除了迈克尔的车，所有人的车胎都被放了。没错。而且他还收到一张仇恨纸条，上面写着，你们烂透了。是范斯冷气公司送的。而且说他们烂透了。因为范斯冷气公司会莫名其妙地突然决定痛恨邓德·米夫林。这太说得通了。但他们偏偏放过了迈克尔的车。好吧，根据迈克尔的说法，他们用仇恨纸条留下了最狠的恶作剧。没错。然后
everyone's like, Oh, come on. They totally know he's full of crap. Now they're really annoyed. But I guess Michael, in some way, Jenna, he was kind of like on the mark because what brings people together more than a common enemy? Yes. The enemy though is Michael. Yeah. Because then you have that great scene of everybody standing around Karen and Phyllis. They have a nice moment. Because Phyllis says, Oh, Bob has an air pump. And they're going to put air in all of our tires so we can get home. And then Karen is like, Oh, you mean Bob Vance from Vance refrigeration? And Phyllis is like, Yeah, she's got it. Yeah, everyone is starting to bond. I can't breeze past the moment though, where Pam clocks Karen scratching Jim's back. Well, scratchy scratchy.
大家都觉得：得了吧。他们完全知道他在胡扯。现在他们真的很恼火。但我想迈克尔在某种程度上，珍娜，他其实有点歪打正着，因为还有什么比一个共同的敌人更能把人们凝聚在一起呢？是的。不过这个敌人恰恰是迈克尔。没错。因为接下来你就会看到那个精彩的场景，大家围站在卡伦和菲利斯身边。他们度过了一个美好的时刻。因为菲利斯说：“哦，鲍勃有一个充气泵。”他们打算给我们所有的车胎打气，这样我们就能回家了。然后卡伦就说：“哦，你是说范斯冷气公司的鲍勃·范斯吗？”菲利斯就说：“对，就是他。”没错，大家都开始融洽相处了。不过，我不能一笔带过帕姆注意到卡伦给吉姆挠背的那个瞬间。好吧，挠呀挠。
This is what I'm saying. They're clearly dating. Why? Why does Jim come into the new office and not tell the new woman that he's dating, that he's kissed the receptionist, and why doesn't he give Pam a heads up? Wishy-washy Jim. Kiss the receptionist. How about the fact that he told her, I love you. I know, we've discussed this. We've talked about this is our beef with Jim. I know, it's our beef with Jim. Well, now Michael's in trouble though. Michael's in trouble because Jan finds out that he fired Tony when Tony was quitting. And now they have to pay Tony a big severance package. Yeah, exactly. And Michael's in trouble with Jan. And he tries to blame Dwight. He's like, well, this was the advice of my number two. And Jan is like, he's, he's not your number two. Jim
这就是我说的。他们显然在约会。为什么？为什么吉姆来到新办公室，却不告诉他正在约会的新女人他吻过前台，为什么他不给帕姆提前透个信？优柔寡断的吉姆。吻了前台。话说他甚至还告诉过她，我爱你。我知道，我们讨论过这个。我们聊过，这就是我们对吉姆的意见。我知道，这就是我们对吉姆的不满。好吧，不过现在迈克尔有麻烦了。迈克尔有麻烦了，因为简发现他在托尼正要辞职时把托尼给解雇了。现在他们必须付给托尼一大笔离职补偿金。没错，确实如此。而且迈克尔惹恼了简。他试图把责任推给德怀特。他说：“嗯，这是我的副手给我的建议。”简却说：“他，他才不是你的副手。吉姆
is your number two. So then Michael calls Jim, Dwight and Andy into his office and makes it seem like he's chosen Jim to be his number two, even though we know from this phone call it was mandated by Jan. And now Dwight and Andy want to know who's your number three. It's so, it's so funny to me that they so quickly gloss over that neither one of them is number two. They're just interested in like, well, now who's number three? Yeah. I mean, I would imagine that Dwight would have been mortified that Jim got number two over him. But I guess now he's just more worried about Andy getting three and having Jim and Andy over him. So everyone's leaving this insane day is done. And Karen calls Jim, he's in his car, invites him out for a drink. Yeah. And Jim's like,
才是你的副手。”于是迈克尔把吉姆、德怀特和安迪叫进办公室，搞得好像是他自己选择吉姆当副手一样，尽管我们从这个电话里知道这是简硬性规定的。现在德怀特和安迪想知道谁是你的三把手。我觉得太好笑了，他们居然这么快就轻描淡写地略过了他们俩都不是二把手的事实。他们只对“好吧，那谁是三把手”感兴趣。是的。我的意思是，我本以为德怀特会因为吉姆当了二把手而羞愧难当，超过了他自己。但我猜他现在更担心安迪当上三把手，并且让吉姆和安迪压在他头上。于是这场疯狂的一天终于结束，大家纷纷离开。卡伦给吉姆打电话，当时吉姆正在车里，邀请他出去喝一杯。没错。吉姆就说：
wait, can I call you right back? Because he sees Pam. And Jenna, is this this moment where Jim is going to try to be real with her? Maybe, but it's too little too late for Pam. She's really stung. She's embarrassed. She would have liked this information. I mean, she really would have behaved differently in this day had she known. And so she kind of cuts him off. You know, he tries to say, oh, hey, I'm sorry, I think things were a little awkward today. And she's like, yep, no, I don't know. See, it was fine. I don't know what you're talking about. And he's like, yeah, well, you know, I'm dating someone. And she's like, yeah, well, you can do what you want, because we're friends. And we'll always be friends. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, she was she was kind of cold in that moment and
“等等，我能马上回给你吗？”因为他看到了帕姆。珍娜，这就是吉姆试图对她坦诚相待的时刻吗？也许吧，但对帕姆来说已经太迟了，无济于事了。她真的深受打击。她很尴尬。她本希望知道这个消息的。我是说，如果她早知道的话，她今天真的会表现得不一样。所以她有点把话头掐断了。你知道的，他试图说：“哦，嘿，我很抱歉，我觉得今天事情有点尴尬。”而她却说：“对，没错，我不知道。看，挺好的。我不知道你在说什么。”然后他说：“是啊，好吧，你知道的，我在跟别人约会。”她就说：“是啊，好吧，你想怎么做就怎么做，因为我们是朋友。而且我们永远是朋友。”没错。没错。没错，她在那个时刻表现得有点冷淡，并且
kind of shut him down. But you know, I see both sides, I see her being hurt. But I also see him as being like, you're not the person I share with anymore. So I don't need to tell you I'm dating anyone. It's none of your business. Oh, yeah. I mean, you know, yeah. Well, Brent Forrester sent us an audio clip about this Jim Pam storyline that runs through this episode. And it's going to seem like I paid him to say this stuff. I just want to preface this clip by saying I did not know he was going to send this in. Oh, let me tell you, there's going to be like balloons and confetti going off when he mentions Jenna's name. He really he really, really admired your performance. Yes. So everyone, this is not a paid endorsement. Go ahead.
有点把话头给堵死了。但你知道，我能理解双方的心情，我能理解她感到了受伤。但我也能理解他的想法，觉得：你已经不再是我会倾诉的对象了。所以我没必要告诉你我在跟谁约会。这不关你的事。哦，是的。我的意思是，你知道的，是的。好吧，布伦特·福斯特给我们发来了一段音频剪辑，谈到了贯穿这一集的吉姆和帕姆的故事线。听起来好像我花钱雇他说这些话似的。我只想在播放这段音频前说明一下，我事先并不知道他会把这个发过来。哦，我跟你说，当他提到珍娜的名字时，现场肯定会有气球和彩纸飞舞。他是真的、真的非常欣赏你的表演。是的。所以各位，这不是付费软文。请听吧。
If you look at the structure of this episode, you can see it was kind of designed to be a classic office episode. It's got that big a story performance piece for Steve Carell, where Michael Scott has twice the audience, twice the family to perform for. And we knew that Steve was just going to kill it in these big performance conference room scenes. We also knew that we had this clash of two comedy characters who had never been in any scenes before. That was Andy Bernard and Dwight Shrut. And sure enough, that two hander is just so funny to watch those guys performing together for the first time. But what really distinguishes this episode is the Jim and Pam story where once again, we relied for the emotion of the episode on Jim and Pam and look at the tremendous
如果你看一下这一集的结构，你会发现它被设计成了一集经典的《办公室》剧集。它有着标志性的A故事表演片段，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔主演，迈克尔·斯科特在这里拥有双倍的观众，双倍的家庭向他们展示演技。我们知道史蒂夫在这些大型会议室表演场景中绝对会大放异彩。我们也知道，我们迎来了两个从未同台飙戏的喜剧角色的碰撞。那就是安迪·德怀特和德怀特·施鲁特。果不其然，那场双人对手戏看起来实在是太滑稽了，看着这俩家伙第一次同台飙戏。但真正让这一集脱颖而出的是吉姆和帕姆的故事，在这里，我们再次把这一集的感情寄托在吉姆和帕姆身上，并且看看这惊人的
performance that Jenna Fisher delivers here. She does so much with so little right from the start where she says, it'll be nice to see my friend again. And you know that what she means is I can't believe Jim and I can get together for the first time. And then watch how she discovers that Jim is dating Karen Philippelli. It's just done in little looks where she notices a piece of gum passed between them. Oh, it kills me, man. It's the greatest performance. And it's part of this tremendous ongoing performance that Jenna Fisher did as Pam Beasley, one of the great performances ever captured on TV, in my opinion. Yeah, it really is. It really is one of the greatest performances ever captured on TV. I wrote that out for him and I felt like he delivered it
表演，这是珍娜·费舍尔在这里呈现的演技。她用极少的台词表达了如此丰富的情感，从一开始她说“能再次见到我的朋友真好”。你知道她的意思其实是“我简直不敢相信吉姆和我有机会第一次真正聚在一起”。然后看她是如何发现吉姆正在和卡伦·菲利佩利约会的。这一切都是通过细微的眼神交流完成的，她注意到了他们之间传递的一块口香糖。哦，天哪，这简直杀了我。这是最棒的表演。而且这是珍娜·费舍尔作为帕姆·比斯利奉献的精彩长线表演的一部分，依我之见，这是电视史上捕捉到的最伟大表演之一。真的，确实如此。这真的是电视史上捕捉到的最伟大的表演之一。我为他写了这段话，我觉得他读得
perfectly. No, thank you, Brent. No, listen, in your defense, it is a fantastic performance. And that that was just a heartfelt message from Brent about how moved he was. And really, everyone is by Jim and Pam, they break our hearts all the time because that is what a sort of star-crossed lovers' courtship is. It's one moment you're available for that other person, either physically or emotionally, and the other person isn't. And then it flips, and they break your heart over and over until they hopefully find each other. Well, here's the thing. You know, I did not make up any of that performance. That was all written for me by the great Brent Forrester. But truly, it's like those directions were in the script.
完美无缺。不，谢谢你，布伦特。听着，平心而论，这确实是一场精彩绝伦的表演。那只是布伦特发自内心的留言，表达了他对吉姆和帕姆的感动。说真的，每个人都被吉姆和帕姆感动过，他们一次次让我们心碎，因为这就是所谓“乱世佳人”式的恋爱追求。往往是一个时刻你对另一个人敞开了心扉，无论是在身体上还是情感上，而另一个人却没有。然后局势反转，他们一次次让你心碎，直到他们最终有望找到彼此。好吧，事情是这样的。你知道的，那些表演我可一点也没瞎编。那全都是伟大的布伦特·福斯特为我写的。但说真的，就好像那些指导说明本来就写在剧本里一样。
I didn't invent those. You know, all of those moments of embarrassment, those were all described to me in the script and I just had to play them. So, you know, that's some of the beautiful detail that we would get in our scripts that I so appreciated as a performer. Those quiet moments that they allowed to play out, those moments of silence, moments of realization. We always took our time with those and it allowed me to, like, really go for it. I loved it. Well, it's great. And that scene broke my heart. There are a lot of moments in this episode where I was just as excited as Pam was that Jim was going to be back and then he's just not available to you. So, it was really hard to watch. Yeah. It's like a brick wall. Like a brick wall.
我可没凭空捏造这些。你知道的，所有那些尴尬的时刻，剧本里都写得清清楚楚，我只需要把它们演出来就行了。所以，你知道的，这就是我们在剧本中能得到的那些精美细节，作为演员我对此感激不尽。那些任由其自然流露的安静时刻，那些沉默的时刻，恍然大悟的时刻。我们总是细细揣摩这些时刻，这让我能够真正全身心投入。我太喜欢了。这太棒了。那一幕真的让我心碎。这一集里有很多时刻，我和帕姆一样兴奋地以为吉姆要回来了，结果他却对你而言不再可及了。所以，看着真的很难受。是的。就像一堵砖墙。就像一堵砖墙一样。
Well, luckily, this episode does not end there. It does not end on Pam's heartbreak or this awkward moment. It ends with a fantastic scene between Andy and Dwight, where they're arguing about their cars, their IQs. They have an amazing, like, coughing. They go, you're an idiot. You're a bigger idiot. I have a fan catch in this final scene. Rhys Persall wrote in and said at 28 minutes 42 seconds, if you're watching the iTunes version. So Dwight and Andy are fighting over their car. Andy's, like, 1985 called once his Trans Am back and Dwight goes, huh, well, it's an 87. So there. But in the pilot, when Dwight is describing his car to Ryan the temp, he says it's a 1978 Trans Am.
好吧，幸运的是，这一集并没有就此结束。它并没有在帕姆的心碎或这个尴尬的时刻结束。它以安迪和德怀特之间的一场精彩戏码收尾，他们俩在争论各自的车，各自的智商。他们有一段精彩的咳嗽戏。他们说：“你是个笨蛋。”“你是个更大的笨蛋。”我在最后这个场景里有一个粉丝抓包。瑞斯·珀索尔来信说，如果你在看iTunes版本，时间在28分42秒。所以德怀特和安迪在为他们的车吵架。安迪说：“1985年打来电话，想要回它的超霸（Trans Am）。”而德怀特则说：“哼，好吧，这是87年的车。怎么样。”但在试播集中，当德怀特向临时工瑞恩描述他的车时，他说这是一辆1978年的超霸。
Oh, all right. So fantastic catch, Rhys. And oh, hold up. Sam is saying he has a little info about this car, Sam. Yeah, I think I can solve this one, actually. I think from the pilot in the first couple of seasons, he has a 1978 Nissan 280Z. And I think you can see it in the grief counseling episode when Pam and Roy walk outside to talk about her new car. And then at some point, he gets a 1987 Pontiac Trans Am. That's the Maroon one you see most of the season. So it's just two different cars. And I know this because I grew up in the 80s in a car family, and my uncle had the first car and my brother had the second car. And I've listened to much Motley Crue in both of them. Sam, applause. Wow. Sam, add to your list muscle car knowledge. I love it. I have one thing I
哦，好吧。所以抓得太棒了，瑞斯。哦，等一下。萨姆说他关于这辆车掌握了一点小信息，萨姆。是的，其实我觉得我可以解开这个谜团。我觉得从试播集和前几季来看，他开的是一辆1978年的尼桑280Z。我想你可以在心理辅导那一集里看到它，当时帕姆和罗伊走到外面去谈论她的新车。然后不知在什么时候，他换成了一辆1987年的庞蒂亚克超霸。就是你在整季里最常看到的枣红色那辆。所以这其实是两辆不同的车。我知道这一点是因为我在80年代的汽车家庭中长大，我叔叔拥有第一辆车，我哥哥拥有第二辆车。而且我在两辆车里听过很多克鲁 Motley Crue 的歌。萨姆，掌声。哇。萨姆，请把肌肉车知识加入你的履历。我太喜欢了。我有一件事
noticed about this scene, Angela. So we know that this elevator goes nowhere. Yeah, we know that when Andy and Dwight stepped into that elevator, it was just a room on a stage. And I clocked the moment when then the elevator doors open and they're suddenly quote unquote downstairs in the lobby. They had to film that at two different times in two different buildings. And you can see the moment that the camera cuts. And that's the moment it starts to move at pans to the left. And then there's a cut. And that is when they were now relocated in the different stage for the exiting of the elevator. And so it's a fun little moment to watch, I think. You and Reese getting all the catches in that final scene. But it looks so seamless. It looks
我注意到了这一幕，安吉拉。所以我们知道这个电梯根本哪儿也不去。是的，我们知道当安迪和德怀特走进那个电梯时，它其实只是摄影棚里的一个房间。我注意到了那个瞬间，电梯门打开，他们突然“所谓地”来到了楼下大厅。他们不得不在两个不同的建筑里分两次拍摄。你能看到镜头剪辑的那个瞬间。那就是它开始移动、镜头向左摇的瞬间。然后画面切了。就在那一刻，他们实际上已经被重新安置到了另一个用于拍摄电梯出口的摄影棚里。所以我觉得这是一个很有趣的小细节。你和瑞斯把最后那个场景里的穿帮全抓出来了。但它看起来是那么天衣无缝。看起来
so seamless. It really seems like that elevator went from one floor to another. Well, I have one deleted scene I want to talk about before we close out the merger here. You know, Jenna, we've talked before that John and I rarely interacted as characters. Yeah, we rarely spoke to each other on camera. Well, in the deleted scenes, there's a scene where Jim goes to accounting. Kevin says that he hid his M&Ms under his desk. If he wants any, they're under his desk. But he didn't want the other people to have them. And then Jim looks at me and goes, Hi, Angela. And I go, you need a haircut. And he goes, Oh, wow. And he goes, Bye, Angela. And he leaves the scene. And that's it. That's all the scene was. But then they left the camera rolling. And we improvised a beat.
是那么天衣无缝。真的感觉那电梯就像是从一个楼层开到了另一个楼层。好吧，在我们在结束合并的剧情之前，我还有一个想聊聊的删减片段。你知道的，珍娜，我们之前聊过，乔恩和我作为角色很少有对手戏。是的，我们在镜头前很少跟对方说话。好吧，在删减片段里，有一幕是吉姆去会计部。凯文说他把M&M巧克力豆藏在办公桌下面了。如果谁想吃，就在他的桌子底下。但他不想让别人吃。然后吉姆看着我说：“嗨，安吉拉。”我说：“你需要理发了。”他说：“哦，哇。”然后他说：“拜拜，安吉拉。”他就离开了这个场景。事情就是这样。整个场景就这么简单。但后来他们让摄影棚的摄像机继续滚动。于是我们即兴发挥了一段。
And it made it in the deleted scenes. So after Jim leaves, Kevin goes, It is his first day back. And I say, his hair is flipping out on the sides. And Kevin goes, I like him. And I say, Oh, my Lord. Well, here's something though, and you said earlier, in the clip that they ended up using of Kevin hiding his M&Ms, you're not even at your desk. I know I would have been there because then Jim would have walked up. I don't know, guys. I'm out. Interesting. I'm hanging out with the plant from the other day. I don't know where I am. I'm yeah, you're with Andy's coat and the plant. Yeah, I'm the three of you. I'm in the box of what are you doing? The box of lost things. Yes. Oh, all right, guys, that was the merger.
并且这段被放进了删减片段里。所以在吉姆离开后，凯文说：“这可是他第一天回来上班。”我说：“他的头发在两边翘起来了。”凯文说：“我挺喜欢他的。”我说：“哦，天哪。”不过这里有个情况，正如你刚才所说，在他们最终采用的凯文藏M&M巧克力豆的剪辑片段里，你甚至都不在你的办公桌旁。我知道我本该在那儿的，因为那样吉姆就会走过来了。我不知道啦，伙计们。我出局了。真有意思。我跟前几天那盆绿植混在一起了。我都不知道我在哪儿。我，是的，你跟安迪的外套和植物待在一块儿。是的，你们三个。我待在那个叫“你在干什么”的盒子里。迷失之物盒子。没错。哦，好吧，伙计们，这就是公司合并的故事。
We want to thank Ken Whittingham and Brent Forrester for sending in those awesome audio clips. Ken is a prolific director. He is directing just about every TV show out there, The Upshaws, American Housewife. Yes, also Bless This Mess, but I will not hold that against you, Ken, because you know, Bless This Mess is the show that replaced my canceled show splitting up together. Oh, but it's okay. It's okay. I'm not bitter. I'll let you guys get into that when he's on Phyllis' wedding. Okay. And Ken left us a little clip saying goodbye and where you can find him on the socials. Thank you so much, Angela and Jenna, for having me do this. Of all the television I've done, some of my best memories are being with you guys on the office. So let's do some more
我们要感谢肯·威廷汉和布伦特·福斯特给我们发来这些精彩的音频剪辑。肯是一位多产的导演。他几乎执导了现今的所有电视剧，《厄普肖一家》、《美国家庭主妇》。是的，还有《祝福这个烂摊子》，但我不会因此对你心存芥蒂，肯，你知道的，因为《祝福这个烂摊子》就是取代了我那部被砍的剧《分居两地》的节目。哦，不过没关系。没关系。我一点也不难过。等他上菲利普的婚礼那一集时，你们再去跟他好好聊聊吧。好的。肯给我们留了一小段音频，跟大家道别，并告诉大家在哪里可以在社交媒体上找到他。非常感谢安吉拉和珍娜邀请我做这个。在我拍过的所有电视剧中，我最美好的回忆之一就是和你们一起在《办公室》里。所以让我们再做多一些
of these podcasts and talk about Phyllis' wedding and some other episodes are done. So Ken Whittingham at Ken Whittingham on Twitter and Kenny Witt on Instagram. And also thank you to Brent Forrester. We're going to have him back again in the future. Guys, Brent Forrester is the head writer for Space Force Season One. And he also online has Brent Forrester's Comedy Knowledge School. It's awesome. It's a six week workshop on half hour comedy writing. You can Google it. You can also find it over on YouTube at Reach Forrester. I love that. I absolutely love that. Well, everybody, that was the merger. Thank you so much for listening in and we can't wait to see you next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by
这样的播客，聊聊菲利普的婚礼以及我们完成的其他剧集。所以肯·威廷汉的推特是 @KenWhittingham，Instagram 是 KennyWitt。同时也要感谢布伦特·福斯特。我们以后还会邀请他回来做客。伙计们，布伦特·福斯特是《太空部队》第一季的主编剧。他在网上还开办了“布伦特·福斯特喜剧知识学校”。太棒了。这是一个为期六周的半小时喜剧编剧工作坊。你可以谷歌搜索一下。你还可以在 YouTube 上搜索 Reach Forrester 找到他。我太喜欢了。我绝对太喜欢了。好了，各位，这就是合并集。非常感谢大家的收听，我们迫不及待地想在下周见到你们。下周见。感谢收听《办公室辣妈》。《办公室辣妈》由
Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Keaton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基顿。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。